[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinkerview nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
alors je peux pas livrer chez vous de
dire je suis scientifique spécialiste de
sciences des matériaux j'ai été
professeur d'université pendant
longtemps
conseillers scientifique dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises et j'ai occupé le
poste de au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique entre 2012 et 2018 et je
conserve une passion et pour l'industrie
pour la science
vous avez oublié que vous étiez académie
des sciences
c'est tout à fait vrai et à deux autres
académies étrangères lesquels l'Académie
européens
on est très content de vous recevoir ce
soir on va parler stratégie on va parler
énergie on va parler nucléaire on va
parler conseil peut-être qu'on parlera
de laquais
des premières questions pour pour se
mettre dans le bain comment vous voyez
les cinq prochaines années pour notre
pays pour notre patrie
je suis là naturel optimiste donc je
pense qu'on est en face on vient de
vivre en électrochoc on commence à se
rendre compte de manière sur le centre
de notre économie qui est notre énergie
on commence à se rendre compte que les
choses vont pas bien du tout et on
commence à se rendre compte qu'on a
laissé filé tout un ensemble de
décisions des raisonnables pendant à peu
près une trentaine d'années et je pense
que cette prise de conscience dans un
pays où il y a encore des jeunes qui ont
envie de faire des choses des
compétences techniques des compétences
industrielles à cette prise de
conscience va conduire à se redresser à
retrousser ses manches et à faire et à
reconstruire notre industrie ça va
mettre du temps donc ce qu'on va voir
dans les 50 qui viennent j'espère c'est
le début de cette reconstruction ça va
pas se reconstruire d'un seul coup mais
je pense que la dynamique j'espère que
la dynamique va se mettre en marche
est-ce que vous pensez que le pays va
subir un trou d'air énergétique qui
pourrait se matérialiser par des
délaissages ou des blackout ou des
coupures d'électricité comme on les
appelle en vrai français ah bah on a en
adresse c'est pas parce que un ministre
je crois que c'est Monsieur Véran qui
nous avait expliqué qu'on aurait pas de
coupure d'électricité qu'on essaye
d'aller voir un décalage entre la
production et la consommation ça ça
suffira pas à éviter d'avoir une pâte
d'électricité donc fondamentalement je
pense qu'on peut avoir on peut on a ce
danger là ça c'est tout à fait clair et
le mur énergétique c'est le mur qu'on a
méthodiquement construit bric-à-brique
depuis 30 ans donc on va se le prendre
maintenant si on peut encore l'amortir
un peu de choc à condition de d'arrêter
de faire n'importe quoi à condition de
de remettre notre parc électronique air
en état à condition de de réfléchir à
comment on construit les nouveaux
réacteurs pas se dire je vais faire des
startups McKinsey je vais faire vraiment
construire des réacteurs donc je pense
qu'on peut le faire mais on a une
question de cinétique c'est à dire on
est en face une situation où il faut
électrifier massivement notre notre
industrie et notre notre société il faut
les clrifier pour les transports pour
les il faut l'électrifier pour le pour
le pour les bâtiments pour le chauffage
dans les bâtiments il y a tous les
aspects numériques qui demandent
d'énormes quantités des d'électricité
donc on doit à la fois électrifier notre
économie et contrairement à ce qu'il y a
écrit l'ADEME pendant 15 ans ou
régulièrement on était en train
d'expliquer qu'on qu'on diminue la
quantité des électricité nécessaire
c'est juste pas vrai donc en même temps
qu'on va augmenter ce besoin
d'électricité on se trouve dans une
situation il faut à nouveau développer
et développer rapidement des ressources
de production des ressources de
transport des ressources de stockage
suivant les modes de production qu'on va
qu'on va avoir et que ça ça se fait pas
par un claquement de doigts il suffit
pas de faire un discours pour construire
une centrale donc ça ça prend du temps
on est gouverné par des brasseurs d'air
chaud et des sculpteurs de fumée on en
reparlera après on reparlera aussi de
réindustrialisation de décarbonation et
tous ces mots qui peuvent être barbares
pour certains
la gamelle on va s'en prendre une où on
va pas s'en prendre une quand j'entends
gamelle c'est-à-dire un trou d'air qui
nous mettrait un petit peu
nos services de soins sous pression qui
nous mettrait avec des petites coupures
d'électricité qui surtout nuirait à
notre croissance est-ce que est-ce que
la gamelle vous la sentez j'ai pas une
vocation d'astrologue j'envoie le risque
je peux jamais garantir que le risque se
traduit par une par une réalisation du
défaut du problème mais maintenant quand
j'entends cet hiver on est on n'est pas
passé loin du désastre en termes de de
blackout et quand j'ai envie de par coup
de bol on a eu il s'est mis à faire un
peu plus chaud et quand j'entends dire
que c'est parce qu'on a bien géré le
problème qu'on l'a réglé non c'est parce
qu'on a un coup de bol mais ça veut dire
que ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de se
mettre en état de gérer correctement le
problème et moyen encore on peut éviter
les désastre moi je suis pas sûr qu'on
puisse tous les éviter c'est quoi se
mettre en état en ordre de marche pour
gérer le problème c'est un arrêté d'être
dans le déni arrêter dans le wishful
d'être dans le wish full thinking c'est
arrêter d'être
dans de la com tout le temps ça veut
dire quoi le plan d'attaque c'est quoi
le plan d'attaque c'est déjà d'arrêter
de faire n'importe quoi parce qu'il y a
une image qui le demande je pense
fondamentalement que d'arrêter 9
centrales avant l'hiver pour des défauts
qui est très lentilles qui étaient très
largement sous critique ça n'était pas
quelque chose de raisonnable je suis pas
en train de dire qu'il fallait pas qu'il
y a des défauts qui étaient largement
souscritique sur des sur des tuyauteries
et des tuyauteries qui va fourrer une
chance sur 1000 d'être utilisé en plus
cet été de secours je dis pas qu'il
fallait pas réparer c'est qu'on aurait
parfaitement pu réparer progressivement
mais on a choisi de régler un problème
de communication plutôt qu'un problème
d'ingénierie et je pense qu'une manière
d'éviter les problèmes maintenant ça va
être de régler des problèmes
d'ingénierie des problèmes de techniques
des problèmes d'industrie plutôt que de
se dire qu'on va régler des problèmes
d'image je crois que ça devient une
urgence et je pense que c'est possible
mais c'est possible à condition d'une
prise de conscience du problème et j'ai
l'impression que cette prise de
conscience est là
vous avez là dans la population dans la
population mais mais dans les politiques
qu'est-ce que ça consiste à quoi au
commissaire à l'énergie atomique ça
consiste à conseiller faire des rapports
qui ne seront jamais lus relier des deux
côtés ça consiste à quoi combien ces
pays d'ailleurs vous êtes payé à faire
ça vous étiez payer en un salaire en
essayant des salariés pour faire ça je
crois de mémoire le salaire devait être
de 10000 euros par mois ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est bien payé c'est un
salaire de haut fonctionnaire c'est un
salaire qui est versé par le CEA mais
qui est décidé par l'assemblée ou par
l'exécutif plutôt c'est un poste qui est
très particulier le poste de
haut-commissaire c'est une bizarrerie
moi je j'avais écouté de dire que
c'était il fallait voir les différents
rôles du gouvernement du
haut-commissaire et de l'administrateur
général moi je le dis une apologue de
marine je disais c'est un peu comme sur
un bateau dans un bateau l'armateur dit
à quel endroit doit aller le bateau le
capitaine dit pour aller à ce bateau là
voilà la trajectoire que je dois prendre
et dit si vous devez faire en prendre
cette trajectoire attention là il y a un
courant ici il y a des écueils par là et
si la boussole se prend la place prend
la place de l'armateur ça n'a pas de
sens si le capitaine décide à la place
de l'amateur ou ce qui doit aller ça n'a
pas de sens non plus donc si vous voulez
un truc comme le CEA c'est quelque chose
dont l'armateur et le gouvernement c'est
lui qui doit décider de la politique le
capitaine c'est l'administrateur général
c'est lui qui prend les décisions pour
réaliser la mission qui lui est donné il
le au commissaire c'est la boussole
alors bon une joue au-delà de cette
histoire là le poste de commissaire a
été créé alors c'est un poste qui il est
très facile de devenir célèbre il suffit
d'être le deuxième à se faire virer pour
des raisons politiques après
Joliot-Curie Joliot-Curie a été le
premier au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique et il avait été nommé c'était
un remarquable physicien nucléaire mais
un moment il a dit je ne participerai
pas je ne participerai pas au
développement de la bombe atomique
contre les frères russes parce qu'il
était membre du PC et on lui dit bah
très bien et donc vous retournez vos
chers études et puis on la remplacé on
l'a remplacer ça après ça a été Francis
Perrin enfin il y a toute une une
dynastie de au commissaire plus ou moins
connue et qui ont tous respecté cette
règle qui est une règle de
d'avoir un travail scientifique de
conseil à la fois auprès de
l'administrateur général et auprès du
gouvernement alors ça ça implique deux
choses ça implique que le haut
commissaire et dans le CEA pour qu'il
puisse savoir exactement ce qui s'y
passe parce que c'est une institution
comme toutes les institutions bien bien
structurées elle est à une capacité
d'enfumage qui est pas du tout
négligeable donc il faut être dedans
pour savoir comment ça marche il faut
essayer dedans pour savoir quelle est la
science qui s'y fait il y a beaucoup de
sciences qui se fait au CEA moi j'ai
trouvé ça absolument passionnant j'ai
appris des tas de choses en biologie que
je connaissais pas du tout par exemple
pendant
deux ans j'ai pris un cours de deux ou
trois heures de cours de biologie que
chaque semaine pour pour essayer de
comprendre non pas les réponses mais au
moins la question donc on a cette
positionnement au sein du CEA mais on a
aussi le positionnement qui est hors de
la hiérarchie du CEA alors divers
administrateurs généraux peuvent
apprécier ça avec des diverses bannières
mais à l'administrateur général qui a
compris ce qui est au commissaire il a
aussi compris le commissaire n'est pas
là pour lui obéir et là pour le
conseiller il est pas là pour décider à
sa place et du coup moi je m'étais donné
une règle en tant que commissaire et qui
était je l'avais dit au gouvernement au
moment où il m'a nommé et ça a très bien
fonctionné avec dos avec deux
administrateurs générales successifs je
dis j'aurais une réserve absolue c'est à
dire les avis que je vous donne ne
sortiront jamais dans la presse t'es pas
donné d'interview dans la presse pendant
les les deux mandats que j'ai occupés
j'ai une réserve absolue mais vous allez
le payer par une franchise absolue c'est
à dire je vous dirais très exactement ce
que je pense avec des argumentations
vous en ferez ce que vous voulez mais
comptez pas sur moi pour pour
enrober les choses donc voilà comment
fonctionne comment j'ai vu le travail de
haute commissaire moi je l'ai vu comme
un travail qui a un travail de
scientifique conseiller du gouvernement
et de l'administrateur général en toute
indépendance vous êtes accrédité secret
défense où tout se crée tous les grades
de ma créditation secret défense et je
ne vous dirai pas comment fabrique une
bombe bâche oui mais maintenant les
plans sont disponibles sur internet donc
vous parlez de bombash on va parler
d'uranium
et on va revenir ensuite sur le conseil
et qu'est ce qu'un bon conseiller la
ressource en
uranium enrichi elle est disponible pas
disponible est-ce qu'il y en aura pour
tout le monde maintenant que le monde
entier souhaite passer à l'énergie
nucléaire est-ce que les mines sont
capables de délivrer de fournir pardon
sont capables de fournir tous ces
projets à l'heure actuelle si mes
souvenirs sont bons on a 441 réacteurs
en état de fonctionner dans le monde il
y en a 200 qui sont en état de
construction
je sais que les Russes fournissent aux
États-Unis d'uranium je sais qu'ils ont
un stock à peu près de 300000 tonnes les
Américains ont un stock de 200000 tonnes
les Français peut-être ont un stock
est-ce que la ressource en uranium
enrichi sera disponible et à quel prix
alors il y a deux questions dans la
notion de la ressource la notion de
réserve a pas de sens il n'y a pas une
notion de prix qui va avec
donc si j'augmente le prix j'ai une
réserve qui devient tout de suite plus
importante il n'empêche que
si le nucléaire se développe comme je
pense qu'il va le faire pour des raisons
de bonnes raisons de sciences
ne serait-ce que pour des carboner nos
industries et notre notre société là le
réserve actuellement dans les tarifs
auxquels on pense pouvoir l'acheter
grosso modo on a en ordre de grandeur
sans 150 ans de réserve c'est-à-dire pas
beaucoup plus que le pétrole alors ça
veut dire que si on veut raisonnablement
penser que le
pour avoir des réserves plus élevées si
on va chercher l’uranium dans la mer
l’uranium dans la mer c'est au
compte-goutte qu'on va le récupérer mais
par contre on a quelque chose qui est
absolument génial qui a été inventé par
Enrico Fermi il y a 80 ans maintenant à
peu près en même temps qu'il a inventé
la pilatomique c'est l'idée que si on
utilise de l'uranition on utilise non
pas des neutrons lents mais des notre
rapide et on veut dire qu'on peut
utiliser beaucoup plus efficacement du
Magnum dont on dispose je peux me
permettre de vous couper on viendra au
neutrons rapide un peu plus tard et un
réacteur neutron rapide un peu plus tard
là je vous parle de technologie
classique c'est une technologie
classique oui mais mais il y a beaucoup
de réacteurs à notre rapide opérationnel
en ce moment il y en a au moins 2 en
Russie il y en a qui en construction aux
États-Unis parce que la Bill Gates qui
est loin d'être un imbécile il a compris
que le nucléaire se développant ce qui
tiendront le verrou du nucléaire c'est
ce qui tiendront les technologies de
neutrons rapides pour faire même si pour
faire baisser donc on va revenir sur ce
et donc ceci la raison pour laquelle je
disais ça c'est que c'est une manière de
démultiplier la ressource l'uranium
naturel vous en utilisez 3% dans un
réacteur c'est rien c'est une
utilisation extrêmement médiocre de la
ressource si vous réussissez à utiliser
beaucoup plus de saturanium en utilisant
l'uranium appauvri la dose sur le coup
vous multipliez de manière considérable
votre ressource vous êtes plus obligé
d'aller creuser des mines dans des pays
plus ou moins louches avec des méthodes
plus ou moins suspectes donc c'est pas
c'est on a essayé de faire croire que
les droits rapides c'était une lubie de
du de scientifiques mais pas du tout
c'est précisément ce qui fait que la
ressource sera disponible sera donc
revenons au réacteur à haute pression
classique avec nos bâtons de
combustibles des fois des bâtons de
combustibles chargés avec du MOX avec un
petit peu de plutonium parce que on
recycle ça c'est un emplâtre sur une
jambe de bois ça
revenons revenons à nos mines d'uranium
classique à notre uranium Henry
classique
la ressource alliée par je crois
qu'actuellement en France on doit avoir
trois ans de ressources trois ans de
réserve en termes d'uranium elle a la
ressource elle va être de plus en plus
cher parce qu'il va de plus en plus de
monde qui va essayer de l'avoir
vous avez fait des rapports là-dessus
parce que vous avez prévenu nous nous
rapports que j'ai pu rendre pendant 6
ans j'ai dû écrire 4000 pages de rapport
pendant 6 ans à la poubelle je sais pas
peut-être qu'ils avaient besoin de caler
des armoires aussi peut-être plus de
papier dans les toilettes ça j'ai pas
imaginé ça qu'est-ce que ça fait de
travailler
un poste ou le conseil scientifique
n'est jamais réuni ou réuni deux fois un
peu à l'arrache ou quand on vous dit
il faut qu'on cale ça dans l'emploi du
temps du ministre vous comprenez c'est
compliqué alors que légalement c'est
obligatoire qu'est-ce que ça fait
travailler avec en face de vous vous
savez pertinemment que ils comprennent
que dalle il se donne même pas le temps
de se s'illuminer les neurones et pour
eux ça passe un petit peu comme un
argument pour faire de la subordination
de vote du côté des écologistes vous
savez les scientifiques comment ils sont
shootés à la compréhension c'est-à-dire
en gros moi je vais passer six ans à
comprendre la science qui se faisait au
CEA essayer de comprendre les différents
aspects de fonctionnement d'une centrale
de vieillissement des matériaux dans la
centrale de l'optimisation des des
combustibles j'ai aussi regardé tous les
problèmes de biologie de la
radioprotection les regarder les
problèmes des sciences fondamentales
qu'on peut avoir dans
l'interaction entre le laser et le noyau
enfin toutes ces choses-là donc
finalement on arrive très bien à se
faire YouTube
la science est un outil de
divertissement absolument faudrait
fantastique mais à un moment quand on
aime bien son pays et qu'on le voit
systématiquement prendre toutes les
décisions stupides qu'on peut qu'on
pourrait parfaitement éviter un moment
vous dites ça suffit et c'est ce que
j'ai fait au bout de j'ai fait deux
mandats successivement au bout du
deuxième mandat j'ai dit bon ben vous
arrêtez une filière à notre rapide je
pense que vous faites une erreur
historique pour le pays c'est pas pour
moi je considère que c'est pas normal et
il y avait quelque chose quelques
quelques points de passage et donc je
leur ai dit bon bah écoutez chercher
quelqu'un d'autre c'est je serai pas
complice
et quand j'étais quand j'utilise le
terme complice il est choisi
c'est de la stupidité c'est de
l'incompétence où c'est de la forfaiture
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire forfaiture
c'est un terme moyenâgeux la forfaiture
c'est un délit de confiance de celui qui
vous a fait confiance c'est
essentiellement ça à la forfaiture
écoutez
c'est pas très facile de répondre à
cette question parce que vous pouvez
avoir droit à des imbéciles vous pouvez
avoir droit à des gens malhonnêtes c'est
pas interdit de cumuler
vous pouvez avoir droit à des gens qui
ont qui pensent que ça sera largement
temps de réagir plus tard on a une
espèce de de
culture de l'immidité qui fait qu'on
s'imagine que j'arrête une centrale
nucléaire comme j'arrête une voiture que
je la redémarrer facilement juste après
que je décide de relancer une filière
comme ça sans problème ou que je décide
de l'arrêter tout pareil donc je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose qui est très
très profond derrière ça c'est d'une
part le fait que le discours a
manifestement remplacé l'action ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que je crame malheureusement qu'on
soit dans une situation où le discours
n'est même pas contraint à la cohérence
et que de manière assez logique quand le
discours n'est pas cohérent et ne
conduit pas une action la parole
n'engage plus alors une fois que vous
faites tout ça moi je sais pas comment
on fait une politique rationnelle
l'action est souvent soeur du rêve quand
on entend Agnès panier ont une haché
vouloir engager 1250 personnes par mois
dans la filière nucléaire jusqu'en 2030
ce qui fait à peu près une quarantaine
de personnes par jour y compris le
dimanche
c'est du pipeau c'est du blabla c'est du
discours est-ce qu'il nous reste des
compétences pour pouvoir engager ces
gens-là est-ce que qu'est-ce qui nous
manque c'est quoi c'est du wish full
thinking c'est on s'agite on s'agite
parce qu'on va laisser des traces à la
télé comme quoi on n'est pas responsable
parce qu'on a essayé de rattraper les
conneries qui ont été faites c'est quoi
écoutez moi quand je vois des gens qui
essayent de rattraper des conneries qui
ont été faites j'ai plutôt tendance à
être positif j'essaye de dire bon de
voir c'est de les aider plutôt de leur
taper dessus maintenant c'est aussi de
leur dire que ça va pas être très bien
ça va pas être facile
maintenant la première chose à faire si
on veut recruter beaucoup de monde
d'ailleurs il faut qu'on se rende compte
que on aura besoin de beaucoup de monde
dans Leclerc on aura besoin de gens de
haute technicité mais il faut se sortir
de de la tête que les soldes gens qu'on
ait besoin de recruter c'est les
ingénieurs ça veut dire qu'il faut
reconstruire tout un tissu d'artisans de
chaudronnier de forgeron de soudeur
aussi bien que des ingénieurs et ça ce
qui rend la chose aussi à la fois
difficile mais aussi d'une certaine
manière si on a une prise de conscience
de l'état de notre industrie aussi très
positif c'est qu'on n'est pas les seuls
c'est une situation les métiers dont je
vous parle ces métiers là on en a besoin
d'un peu près toutes les industries qui
fabriquent quelque chose donc ça veut
dire je pense qu'on est dans une
situation on est en train de voir dans
toute son évidence dans sa la crudeur de
son évidence le fait que il faut
absolument se redonner les outils
intellectuels manuels physiques pour
pouvoir fabriquer des choses et parmi
les choses qu'on doit fabriquer il y a
une centrale nucléaire mais il y a pas
que ça finalement il y a relativement
peu de compétences nécessaires dans le
nucléaire qui soit nécessaire que pour
le nucléaire vous avez besoin de notre
onitien c'est vrai que les neutronicien
vous avez pas les utiliser à beaucoup
d'endroits à part pour faire des
centrales maintenant
des gens qui font de la mécanique des
fluides des gens qui font de la
mécanique des solides des gens qui font
de la thermique vous allez trouver ça
dans tous les domaines industriels et là
je parle que de la filière de la filière
ingénieur maintenant si je parle de la
filière des techniciens tout ce
savoir-faire dont on a besoin pour
fabriquer des objets pour pouvoir les
assembler pour pouvoir en suivre le les
suivre de manière non destructive vous
allez quand vous allez regarder les
différentes filières industrielles vous
allez retrouver les mêmes alors il se
trouve que moi j'ai eu la chance avant
d'être au commissaire énergétique comme
j'ai fait de la science des matériaux
c'est un des matériaux c'est quelque
chose qui est assez assez
fascinant pour quelqu'un de curieux
c'est que les matériaux il y en a
partout et donc ça veut dire que
naturellement en faisant de la science
des matériaux je m'intéressais aux
automobiles je m'intéressais à
l'aviation je veux m'intéresser au
nucléaire je m'intéressais aux
médicaments et vous vous apercevez quand
vous faites ça qu'en plus vous êtes prof
c'est-à-dire que vous formez des gens
voyez l'ensemble des domaines dans
lesquels les gens qui vont vous former
sont nécessaires et je pense que quand
madame peut dire une Acher dit il faut
embaucher beaucoup de monde à la raison
on va pas pouvoir le faire facilement
mais commence à se mettre en état de
mettre en place les formations pour
pouvoir le faire mais surtout en ce
qu'on peut aussi imaginer c'est de c'est
de former des gens à partir de domaines
dans lesquels ils sont déjà actifs je
pense qu'il est toute une réaginerie de
la formation qu'on a absolument pas en
France déshabiller Paul pour habiller
Jacques non non c'est pas ça mais je dis
il y a des secteurs vous avez des
secteurs qui ont été complètement
dévastés comme les acteurs de
l'industrie textile il y a des
compétences qui existaient à cet endroit
là qu'on a retrouvé Dieu c'est où elles
sont peut-être maudits remobilisables ce
que je dis c'est que il faut penser
d'une manière d'une façon globale
le nucléaire n'est que la partie émergée
de l'isberg le problème du nucléaire le
problème de l'industrie nucléaire en
France et le problème d'un pays qui
s'est méthodiquement des industrialisés
depuis 30 ans pourquoi je sais pas j'y
étais pas moi je veux dire à l'époque
moi je faisais essentiellement de la
science des matériaux je format des
étudiants mais je pense que le fait que
le pays se soit industrialisés c'est
d'une certaine manière il a cessé de
croire à son avenir en son avenir il a
surtout commencé à croire à des à des
fauxeurs à des gens qui vous disaient je
rêve d'avoir une industrie sans usine
président du pouvoir d'achat voilà des
choses comme ça enfin bon et donc quand
vous avez des gens qui vous disent des
choses soit qui sont pas vrai qu'ils ne
savent pas ou qu'ils le savent ça change
pas vraiment le problème vous vous
endormez les gens vous leur dites mais
il y a pas de problème on va pouvoir
construire de la richesse sans
construire des choses c'est peut-être
une il n'y a pas très longtemps j'ai
expliqué je faisais pas mon coming out
marxiste mais je disais grosso modo pour
moi on crée de la richesse dans un pays
quand on transforme de la matière en
produits en utilisant de l'énergie et du
savoir et ça c'est les quatre pieds qui
font qu'on a une économie qui se
développe et je pense qu'on a oublié ça
et en oubliant ça on a oublié qu'il
fallait fabriquer des objets on s'est
dit on s'est dit dans une espèce
d'aberration mentale que l'industrie on
allait faire fabriquer en Chine et puis
on avait où nous chargé de le vendre
c'est d'une inculpture crasse je veux
dire penser que la Chine à 4 millions de
commerce derrière elle quand vous êtes
allés en Chine que vous voyez qu'il y a
un magasin à peu près tous les 5 mètres
il faut quand même être dans une
inculture monumentale pour s'imaginer
qu'on va la refaire fabriquer des trucs
et que c'est nous qui allons les vendre
donc ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
réapprendre et je pense que la
population est en train de réapprendre
que il va falloir que l'on reconstruire
une industrie complètement et pas
simplement le nucléaire vous dites que
l'énergie c'est le sang de notre
économie la sève de notre économie le
sang vous avez
on a aussi ce point de vue là mais de
temps en temps sur internet il y a des
gens qui nous rappellent que l'énergie
par rapport au PIB
ça baisse de plus en plus c'est le PIB
augmente quand même c'est quoi c'est la
différence avec la dette qu'on injecte à
l'intérieur c'est c'est les gens qui
font du blabla font beaucoup de PIB
expliquer moi ce concept de sang de
l'économie du concept de sang de
l'économie de le PIB fondamentalement
j'ai jamais eu bien compris compris je
vais pas faire semblant j'ai jamais
compris moi je veux dire pour moi
l'économie c'est un truc que je ne
comprends pas parce que je ne comprends
pas une discipline où il y a pas de loi
de conservation donc c'est tout alors
donc je vais pas vous en parler parce
que je préfère parler des choses que je
connais alors maintenant pourquoi je dis
que c'est le sang de l'économie parce
qu'il n'y a pas une activité dans
l'économie une activité industrielle qui
ne nécessite pas de l'énergie et quand
on me parle d'une économie
dématérialisée je vous dis vous les
faites fonctionner avec quoi vos centres
de calcul donc l'économie l'énergie
c'est ce qui permet de faire tout ce
qu'on peut faire dans une économie
industrielle alors maintenant on peut
aussi se dire je veux pas d'économie
industrielle parfait vous voulez faire
que de l'agriculture bah c'est pas
vraiment facile de faire l'agriculture
sans devoir d'énergie donc c'est on la
trouve partout l'idée du sang de
l'économie c'est parce que dans un corps
humain vous avez du sang jusque dans les
les plus extrêmes parties du corps
humain ça passe dans les artères ça
passe dans les capillaires il y en a
partout et si ça ne va pas partout et
bien là les choses se nécrose je pense
qu'on est exactement dans sur la si on
n'a pas une économie une énergie
disponible notre tissu industriel se
nécrose alors maintenant je vais
terminer avec ça ça veut dire que ça
veut pas dire que je crois qu'il y a un
mythe qui est de dire je vais avoir une
énergie abondante tout le temps je pense
que c'est pas vrai mais je pense que et
je suis pas décroissantis dans l'âme je
vais peut-être choqué des gens mais moi
j'ai plutôt que le terme de sobriété qui
a été un petit peu galvaudé parce qu'il
a un côté punitif qui me déplaît assez
il y a quelque chose qui pour moi est
très important c'est la parcimonie c'est
le fait d'utiliser au mieux la ressource
et l'énergie la ressource de matière en
termes d'énergie en termes de d'espace
ces ressources là il faut les utiliser
au mieux donc ça veut dire que en même
temps qu'on va essayer de d'utiliser ça
au mieux il faut qu'on soit en état de
de d'optimiser l'usage de façon à ce
qu'on puisse progressivement continuer à
faire des choses en ayant pas forcément
toujours autant d'énergie donc ce que je
veux dire simplement c'est que c'est
idiot de me dire c'est pas la peine
d'isoler les bâtiments parce que
l'électricité des carbonée c'est stupide
parce que si vous faites l'inventaire
des trucs qu'il va falloir électrifier
entre le bâtiment le l'automobile le
lundi un certain nombre de procédés
industriels il va y avoir carence on va
avoir des difficultés à fournir toute
l'électricité dans on a besoin donc ça
veut dire que pour pouvoir le faire et
bien il va falloir l'utiliser au mieux
il va falloir avoir des procédés qui
sont de plus en plus efficaces il va
falloir avoir des bâtiments qui sont de
mieux en mieux de mieux en mieux isoler
il va falloir des véhicules qui seront
de plus en plus légers parce que si on
fait pas ça on va gaspiller l'énergie
donc je pense que c'est il faut il faut
penser quand je dis que l'énergie est le
centre de notre économie ça veut dire
qu'il faut penser l'ensemble donc vous
avez l'énergie dont on a impérativement
besoin il y a l'espace et avec les
compétitions d'usage de l'espace pour ça
l'énergie nucléaire est absolument
excellente je veux dire on produit
énormément sur pas beaucoup de surface
l'utilisation de la matière est
importante aussi je veux dire si vous
pensez en termes de souveraineté quand
vous dites la matière je suis en train
de l'importer ok
on a beaucoup glosé sur les terres rares
sur tous ces choses-là parfois mais
dites-vous que la France c'est un pays
qui
exporte des ferrailles et qui importe de
l'acier chercher l'erreur avec le prix
de l'électricité des grondage chercher
l'erreur quand vous prenez une ferraille
vous la faites dans passer dans un four
électrique vous en refaites de l'acier
donc là ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il y a aussi une réflexion à avoir
qui est sur le recyclage massif des
matériaux en grande quantité et de
savoir comment je peux le faire est-ce
que c'est économiquement viable est-ce
que c'est énergétiquement faisable et je
pense que c'est cette réflexion
d'ensemble qu'on a pas depuis longtemps
et qu'il faudrait remettre pour moi ce
que j'attends d'un politique qui soit
capable d'avoir cette vision d'ensemble
et qui soit capable de mettre en ordre
de marche les forces vives d'un pays
pour pouvoir avoir quelque chose de
viable sur cet ensemble là si on n'y
arrive pas qu'est-ce qui va se passer
aussi on y arrive pas on va se retrouver
comme
parc d'attraction pour touristes
asiatique mais moi je pense que mon mon
passeport vaut mieux que ça
ça vous a fait quoi de voir ces inities
en termes de ces initiés en termes de
décision depuis les 15 dernières années
est-ce que vous avez essayé de sonner la
cloche sonner l'alarme en disant il y a
un problème il faut n'importe quoi ils
sont en train de se payer avec de la com
sur le patrimoine que nos groupons que
les Français ont développé depuis les 70
dernières années ils sont ils ne font
pas les investissements est-ce que les
scientifiques se sont mis un petit peu
en guilde pour dire là ils emmènent le
pays à volo ça va faire un peu n'importe
quoi on a 10 ans on va se prendre un mur
on va se prendre une grosse gamelle et
ils seront plus là ils seront ils seront
pas responsables ils seront pas
coupables ils sont ils seront
responsables mais pas coupables est-ce
que est-ce que les scientifiques
français que vous avez pu côtoyer ou que
vous côtoyez toujours se disent on est
dirigé par une bande de deux je vous
laisse terminer la phrase
[Musique]
je pense que comment je vais vous dire
ça
dans le poste que j'occupais je m'étais
imposé de ne pas parler pour les raisons
que je vous aimez à la presse par contre
je peux vous garantir que au décideur
j'ai parlé en large et en travers ici à
un moment où
non élevé
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des moments où
j'ai eu des petits moments d'agacement
quand même et bon je l'ai dit d'ailleurs
c'est mais d'une certaine manière je
l'ai aussi j'avais aussi discuté avec
les avec les députés je me souviens
d'une réunion qui était absolument
absolument fascinante avec des députés
de ça devait être ça devait s'appeler la
République en marche à l'époque
j'avais été sympathisant
parfait il y avait une il y avait une
réunion j'avais fait une réunion avec un
certain nombre de députés c'est être une
trentaine et qui s'intéressait au
problème d'énergie et je leur ai dit
mais enfin c'est juste pas possible il y
a une gazette de sujets sur les
problèmes d'énergie de sujet majeurs
vous mettez à deux sur chaque sujet vous
vous donnez 6 mois pour bosser
sérieusement ces sujets là vous viendrez
pas des experts mais vous serez capable
de pouvoir challenger les experts vous
serez capable de pouvoir aller les
titiller allez les les gratter leur dire
là je comprends pas ce que vous me dites
etc et là j'ai eu cette réponse
absolument fascinante c'est on n'a pas
le temps
et donc je pense que j'aurais eu la
réponse la même réponse dans n'importe
quel conglomérat de députés mais ça veut
dire quoi cette chose là c'était pas
plus mauvais que les autres ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on a on a quelque
chose qui sait très profondément entrer
dans la société telle qu'on la vise et
c'est pour ça qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir une réveil c'est cette espèce de
d'illusion d'enfant gâté que les choses
vont se faire naturellement qu'il y a
rien à faire pour résoudre les problèmes
que eux ils vont se résoudre qu'il
suffit qu'on fasse un beau discours
enfin etc etc mais ça c'est pas que le
politique qui est comme ça alors
maintenant le le
quand vous regardez l'évolution de
l'enseignement des sciences à l'école
mais ça se c'est ça se tirer des plombs
je veux dire vous en arrivez en
terminale à faire des programmes on
explique aux gamins ce que c'est que le
boson de Higgs juste pas possible qu'ils
comprennent donc on les apprend à parler
autour de chez présidé pendant 12 ans le
Conseil scientifique de la Fondation la
main à la patte dans la fonction et de
d'aider les enseignants à amener la
science à l'école a amené le
raisonnement scientifique chez les
enfants c'est ils ont fait un boulot
superbe c'est un truc qui a été créé par
sharpak qui irait Elena qui existe qui
existe toujours qui marche bien mais ils
ont un mal fou à se faire soutenir par
le ministère simplement parce que c'est
pas neuf donc vous êtes dans une
situation ou en gros l'image il y a une
espèce de 2 de fascination non pas pour
la ski origine ils a besoin d'être neuf
ça doit d'être nouveau c'est et quand
vous faites des trucs comme ça vous
allez vous dire c'est un peu ce qu'il y
a derrière cette idée qu'il suffit
d'annoncer de faire passer quatre slides
sur un sur une start-up et puis pape ça
y est c'est génial les gens que j'ai
rencontré dans les conseils ministériels
c'est juste ses parents veuillez des
gens pour qui une industrie c'était
fabriqué des applis pour mon iPhone
c'est pas que ça ça peut être ça mais ça
n'est pas que ça
vous avez pas essayé de créer une
association pour essayer de mettre un
peu de connaissances scientifiques chez
nos chers politiques j'ai renseigné
pendant deux ans à Léna
parce que je me suis dit exactement ça
je me suis dit bonsoir tu peux pas râler
tout le temps comme ça il faut bien
faire un peu quelque chose quoi et le
directeur de l'ENA qui était quelqu'un
de très très bien l'époque qui depuis
été viré d'ailleurs
qu'en même temps qu'on a cassé le bocal
on a cassé le vivier je veux dire donc
j'ai passé deux ans j'ai fait des cours
à l'ENA pendant deux ans et je leur
faisais un cours sur l'instruction
scientifique des dossiers politiques
c'était trois fois deux heures de cours
après encaisser la croûte ensemble et je
passais trois fois deux heures à
discuter avec les étudiants qui le
souhaitaient
c'était fascinant c'était superbe je
voyais des gens qui a eu envie de servir
leur pays qui sentait que la science
était importante et qu'ils avaient envie
de comprendre alors moi c'est la
question que je me pose c'est que cela
qui sont là et qui demande pas mieux ou
est-ce qu'ils passent quelle est la
moitié de lambica connard qui fait que
on distille en distillant tout sauf
ceux-là donc moi une fois que j'ai vu ça
je me suis dit bon il y a une
possibilité de reconstruire ça et je
l'ai dit dans mon audition à l'Assemblée
nationale entre 1946 et
1964 vous aviez Louis Armand
l'arrière-grand-père du rapporteur de la
commission qui donnait un cours sur la
science et les technologies
industrielles de la France et donner ça
un cours aux promotions des narcs et ça
veut dire que quand ils avaient eu ce
cours là ils étaient pas ingénieurs mais
ils savaient pourquoi c'était important
moi je suis en train de travailler avec
avec Jean-Paul goutte et à réédité ce
cours là non pas comme l'exemple de de
ce qu'on doit savoir tout de suite parce
qu'il y a des tas de choses qu'on savait
pas une époque qu'on sait maintenant
donc dire qu'il y aura un deuxième
volume qui sera quoi de neuf depuis
Louis Armand mais cette aida d'esprit de
dire Léo fonctionnaires qui nous
gouvernent doivent savoir ce qui est
important ils doivent être capables de
pouvoir interroger des experts et de
pouvoir les titiller juste là jusqu'à ce
que les experts soient claires les
meilleurs conseillers que j'ai rencontré
dans les ministères étaient des énarques
qui ne connaissaient pas la science mais
qu'ils savaient que c'était important
j'en ai vu quelques-uns comme ça 5 sur
50 à peu près et donc oui mais je
voulais donnerai pas la torture même
sous la torture le name dopping n'est
pas mon style c'est positif et même
c'est cela c'était des gens qui savaient
que c'était important ils savaient
qu'ils ne savaient pas et comme ils
étaient bien câblés tant que j'avais pas
expliqué clairement ce que je voulais
dire il veut lâchait pas la grappe tant
que vous n'avez pas excitant que j'ai
pas compris c'est que vous n'avez pas
bien expliqué ce qui était vrai les
pires étaient les ingénieurs du
mont-estampillé avec un tampon sur le
front
qui avait fait de la science mais qui
n'avait jamais pratiqué et qui dans un
milieu qui est essentiellement
dessérébré d'un point de vue
scientifique et technique passé comme
les flambeaux de la lumière ça c'est des
calamités donc je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir aussi se remettre dans une
situation où on peut avoir des
conseillers qui font leur boulot
et cela ne sont pas forcément des
scientifiques mais par contre ça doit
être des gens qui savent aller chercher
la connaissance où elle se trouve vous
avez je fais partie de l'académie des
sciences vous l'avez rappelé l'Académie
des Sciences l'Académie des technologies
bon ben ça a été l'Académie de
technologie est plus récente mais
l'Académie des Sciences a été créée par
Colbert pour conseiller Louis XIV en
date un petit peu quand même
l'Académie des Sciences a été
technologies sur le sujet dont nous
parlons le sujet de l'énergie on pendu
une quantité de rapport qui est énorme
je n'ai jamais vu ces rapports lui cité
ou même utiliser dans les ministères et
pourtant une les recevait ça c'est de
votre faute il fallait mettre des
coloriages dedans
bon du côté du côté des militaires parce
que l'énergie atomique aussi côté
militaire ils connaissent bien
vous les avez senti un peu plus érudit
est-ce que vous avez discuté du Cap que
le pays était en train de prendre avec
eux est-ce que les militaires étaient un
peu plus affûtés que nos politiques
alors
comment je vais vous dire ça parce que
quand j'étais jeune parce que ça date un
peu je dois dire que j'étais pas
vraiment militariste enthousiaste
faisait partie de je faisais partie de
ces polytechniciens qui bon il voulait
bien il voulait bien avoir le uniforme
parce qu'il était joli quoi et puis
progressivement je me suis aperçu que
ceux qui tenaient la boutique dans le
domaine de l'énergie nucléaire c'était
les militaires les gens qui ont pas
perdu de vue la chose qui ont qui ont
une mission clairement identifiée qui
savait de toute façon l'arme nucléaire
et la dissuasion on a deux sens que si
on a par ailleurs la propulsion et que
la propulsion n'est possible que si on a
les capacités de les capacités de faire
des réacteurs et de fabriquer des pompes
et d'avoir toutes du combustible et ça
ça ne s'est jamais perdu donc de ce
côté-là ça a été ça a été le phare ça a
été l'endroit où l'idée ne s'est pas
perdu et moi je suis très reconnaissant
en haut aux militaires dans le domaine
de dans le domaine de l'édition y
compris y compris et pas que y compris
ceux qui se trouvait à la présidence de
la République c'était un île aux états
n'îlot de raisons à cet endroit là
et ça reste un îlot de raison ça restera
toujours
comment comment vous percevez
ce cap de
pas de décision de mauvais conseiller on
conseille le roi ou le prince on veut
jamais le froisser on lui dit ce qu'il
veut entendre quand on fait de la
subordination de vote avec certains
autres partis politiques ça vous fait
quoi pour le pays de voir ça
à l'intérieur
décrivez-nous votre votre sentiment vous
rentrez chez vous vous cassez des
assiettes par terre vous dites moi j'ai
une conformation qui fait que pour
éviter ça à l'estomac je me mets en
colère donc ça permet ça permet de
dissiper les l'énergie mais bon blague à
part c'est vrai qu'on a on a une
certaine agacement quand on aime son
pays et qu'on voit ce qui se commence à
se ça se passe c'est un agacement qui
est qui est mêlée c'est-à-dire on se dit
c'est juste pas possible qu'il voit pas
quoi c'est et ben pourtant si
mais il voit pas c'est-à-dire que vous
vous avez la capacité en fait
d'extrapoler les conséquences de leur
misérabilité intellectuel ou de leur
passivité intellectuelle donc vous avez
les capacités en fait de projeter
d'extrapoler les conséquences sur notre
société notre industrie notre système de
santé notre démocratie
c'est ça qui vous faut particulièrement
encore une fois
il est illusoire quand on a quand on a
une situation qui c'est à ce point
dégradé de s'imaginer qu'il y a en gros
un responsable ou un ensemble de
responsables
ce qui se passe c'est la chose suivante
j'ai été très dur sur les conseillers il
y en a des très bons ceux qui sont pas
bons c'est très grave parce que c'est la
capacité c'est l'adaptation d'impédance
vis-à-vis des connaissances dont on a
besoin pour décider voilà l'exemple que
j'aime bien donner quand même on n'a pas
besoin de scientifiques comme politique
c'est pas vrai je veux dire Pompidou
était agrégé de grammaire mais c'était
quelqu'un qui était suffisamment
intelligent pour savoir ce qui savait
pas
son premier ministre est lancé le plan
Messmer il était juriste et ancien
légionnaire mais c'est quelqu'un qui
était assez assez droit pour en avoir
rien d'autre à faire que de servir son
pays et pas de servir sa carrière vous
aviez ensemble derrière ça vous aviez
une
c'est quelqu'un d'absolument
extraordinaire toute brasse
vous aviez ensuite vous aviez un tissu
industriel des grands industriels de
l'énergie de l'énergie atomique par
cette boiteux qui a passé 100 ans cette
année c'est pour moi l'archétype du
grand serviteur de l'État vous aviez
d'autres personnes Jean-Marc Lenny qui
était le patron de framatum vous aviez
Michel Hughe qui était qui a été le
grand ingénieur qui a organisé toute
l'organisation de la construction du
parc et Michel legue est mort il y a 3
ans pas une ligne il a fallu que j'en
fasse les loges dans la journée la rouge
alors que c'était le monsieur qui avait
mis en place la totalité de la stratégie
d'organisation industrielle pour pouvoir
construire en même temps dans une année
six réacteurs je veux dire si on veut
reconstruire le nucléaire la première
chose qu'il faut faire c'est d'aller
voir les gens qui ont travaillé avec
Michel Luc ils vont vous dire comment on
fait pour fondre pour faire fabriquer
des centrales et je veux dire c'est cet
ensemble là qui a fait que dans une
situation de crise qui était la
situation de la crise pétrolière avec un
pays qui de doutait pas de lui il s'est
mis au boulot il l'a construit moi j'ai
la faiblesse de penser qu'on peut encore
le faire mais grosso modo il faut
trouver l'équivalent et donc que je vous
ai donné
Bernard n'est pas encore mort mais
attendez encore une un exemple j'ai eu
la chance c'est de c'était la chance de
ma fonction peut-être la chance de ma
barbe blanche aussi de rencontrer
quelques-uns des papiers qui ont
construit ou congés le parc
électro-du-clair voir qui sont allés
construire les usines à taïshan il y a
la première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
de leur dire bon ben vous nous donnez un
coup de main vous avez plus de carrière
à faire mais vous avez un pays vous
l'avez aimé vous l'avez servi aidez-nous
aidez-nous éviter de faire les boulettes
qu'on vient de faire méthodiquement
pendant les 20 dernières années
c'est des boulettes ou c'était c'est pas
des boulettes
trouver les décisions politiques ont été
prises quand on voit notre liste de
l'économie l'écologie
négocier la sortie du nucléaire et quand
on voit les les baisses de du
pourcentage de nucléaire dans notre mix
énergétique c'est fait à l'arrache il y
a aucune projection il y a aucune
anticipation des conséquences non mais
là je parlais des boulettes qu'on avait
faites au point de vue de construction
industrielle on a construit pendant 20
ans maintenant les boulettes au niveau
des décisions politiques je veux dire
c'est c'est l'harmonieux mélange c'était
mon Rango qui disait que il avait une
expression que je trouvais magnifique
mais il disait qu'on voyait les effets
dévastateurs de la de l'alliance entre
les les incompétents les les
incompétents les doctrinaires et les
plus ilanimes
c'était son résumé de la situation
une phrase très joyeuse sur la
proportion de connards
c'est le général Saunier qui accueillait
les promotions de polytechnier ma
promotion comme ça il disait messieurs
je tiens à vous dire que la proportion
des cons et la même partout mais ils
sont d'autant plus dangereux qui sont
plus soigneusement choisis je trouvais
que c'était très savoureux et c'était
très bien vu c'était et de deux de dire
ça des jeunes qui arrivent à qui on
vient d'expliquer que ça y est ils ont
gagné le ils ont gagné le pompon c'est
plus intelligent du monde ça remettait
toutes les pendules à l'heure et ça
faisait énormément de bien vous parlez
de la situation qui est à ce point
dégradé ça veut dire quoi est-ce que
vous pouvez mettre des mots essayer de
délayer cette situation à ce point
dégradé
alors une situation à ce point dégradé
il y a plusieurs choses elle peut être
dégradée industriellement ça ça se voit
c'est bien quand même je veux dire le
nombre le nombre d'industries qu'on a
perdu dans les dans les 20 dernières
années qu'on a vendu qu'on a abandonné
qu'on a qu'on a juste laissé disparaître
c'est farameux quoi donc ça c'est
dégradation physique j'en prends mais je
pense qu'il y a une dégradation
mentale il y a eu un vieillissement de
la population dans sa tête au lieu de se
dire qu'est-ce que je peux faire on
s'est demandé de plus en plus qu'est-ce
que je peux craindre et ça c'est une
dégradation qui est très très profond
moi j'ai un peu enseigné en Chine et en
Corée j'enseigne aussi au Canada et en
Australie je vois jamais ça dans les
étudiants
jamais je vois des étudiants qui disent
comment on fait qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
comment est-ce qu'on construit et je
veux dire je pense que on a aussi cette
possibilité on a aussi ça chez les
étudiants en France mais à l'étage
au-dessus on a l'impression qu'il faut
surtout pas faire quoi c'est
la question internet je la prends au
passage
que penses-tu brescher du fait que ces
mails avec les équipes de Macron en 2017
pendant qu'il était au commissaire au
CE1 ont fuité dans les Macron lixes
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure j'avais
parti des gens qui ont été conquis qui
sont
je sais pas moi il y a un langage qui
m'avait plu parce que je pensais que
fondamentalement on avait on avait un
vrai problème déjà je veux dire en est
en train d'essayer de taper sur Macron
maintenant parce que c'est la cerise sur
une pyramide de bêtises quoi enfin je
veux dire c'est pas c'est il est pas
responsable de tout ce qu'on veut lui
mettre sur le dos facilement
à l'époque le langage c'était
il y a des bonnes idées partout il faut
les mettre en oeuvre c'était on
n'avancera pas si on n'arrive pas à
mobiliser l'ensemble du pays à le faire
avec bienveillance il y avait ce fameux
discours de Villepinte où je dois laver
après par cœur non pas tout le discours
mais il faut absolument que l'expertise
revienne au cœur du processus de
décision
trois choses comme ça pour un
scientifique qui est bien son pays bien
oui j'ai été conquis
j'avais pas envie de faire une carrière
politique c'est pas mon truc c'est
vraiment pas mon truc mais donc j'assume
le fait d'avoir été conquis mais je dis
que j'ai été déçu
et donc que ce soit sorti dans les
macroniques alors j'en ai juste
absolument rien à cirer
parlons un petit peu de
[Musique]
des réacteurs à neutrons rapides pour
fermer le cycle du nucléaire est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est
d'ailleurs d'abord fermer le cycle du
nucléaire et ensuite le neutron rapide
alors fermez le cycle de nucléaire ça
veut dire que il faut essayer d'utiliser
le produit c'est à dire les déchets qui
viennent d'une centrale pour en faire un
combustible pour la même centrale c'est
ça fermer le cycle c'est à dire ne pas
accumuler les déchets et multiplier la
ressource donc l'ensemble de ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle fermer le cycle nucléaire
alors dans un réacteur à neutrons Lens
c'est pas très facile parce que vous
prenez de l'uranium vous êtes obligé de
l'enrichir un réacteur c'est grosso modo
c'est une machine à faire une économie
de neutrons qui est couplé avec une
machine à vapeur c'est ça rect mes
collègues de physique nucléaires
détestent quand je dis ça mais c'est
quand même essentiellement ça alors
l'économie de neutrons ça veut dire que
vous devez enrichir le combustible et
vous devez vous débrouiller pour que les
neutrons partent pas pas trop d'une
certaine manière
votre plutonium votre uranium ce qui
n'est pas fissionné redevient du
plutonium le plutonium lui-même se
dégrade donc en fait vous vous trouvez
avec quelque chose qui fait un bilan à
peu près constant en plutonium et il
réutilisation de l’uranium donc c'est
jackpot 3 citrons vous avez moins de
déchets en aval et vous avez des et vous
avez une meilleure utilisation de
l'uranium donc au lieu d'avoir sans
temps de réserve vous retrouvez avec
1000 ans de réserve quand même pas mal
Milan moi je sais pas ce qu'il y aura
dans 1000 ans donc voilà la logique des
réacteurs à notre rapide c'est pas une
idée nouvelle c'est une idée qui est qui
est due Enrico Fermi comme beaucoup
d'idées en physique nucléaire mais c'est
une idée qui était mise en oeuvre dans
un certain nombre de réacteurs
expérimentaux et la France avait
véritablement une avance dans ce
domaine-là grâce à un très grand
monsieur qu'on a aussi oublié qui
s'appelle George vandries qui a
d'ailleurs écrit un petit livre sur sur
les réacteurs à de trop rapide vous
voulez comprendre comment ça marche ce
qu'il y a dedans c'est Facebook là alors
vendriez c'était le père de super
Phoenix de Phoenix et de super Phénix
quand on a arrêté Phoenix et super
Phénix le ce qui s'est passé c'est que
moi c'est une des choses que j'ai faite
quand j'étais au commissaire c'est il y
avait des connaissances énormes qui
avaient été accumulées je me suis dit il
faut surtout pas que ça se perde ce truc
là donc parce que j'en ai jamais à
l'abri d'une connerie de décision
politique qui arrêterait Astrid par
exemple
et donc j'ai fait écrire deux bouquins
un bouquin le retour d'expérience de
Phoenix et un bouquin le retour
d'expérience de super Phénix le retour
d'expérience c'était le retour
d'expérience
scientifique mais aussi le retour
d'expérience industrielle et ces livres
ont été écrits par quelqu'un qui
s'appelle Joël guidez avec toute une
équipe qui comprenait des gens du CEA
des gens de framatum et des gens des DF
donc d'une certaine manière c'est le
repos repositoire de ce qui était un
trésor scientifique français d'ailleurs
Joël guidez passe son temps maintenant à
aller faire des séminaires partout sur
le globe parce que les gens savent qu'on
a cette cette connaissance là cette
connaissance là et pas secrète mais je
voulais au moins qu'on la perte de pas
alors Astrid ça a été quoi alors après
l'arrêt de super Phénix qui était qui
était le truc qui a été fait par un
petit arrangement entre amis entre les
Verts et le PS encore une fois et à
l'époque c'était monsieur Jospin et
Madame Voynet l'arrêt de superficie
a conduit à éviter on a essayé d'éviter
que tout se perdre et puis après il y a
eu un relancement directeurs à notre
rapide parce que de temps en temps il y
a des politiques qui comprennent un peu
qui a quelque chose d'important à faire
là et ben oui mais quand ça arrive il
faut les applaudir quand même donc les
le projet le projet Astrid a été relancé
sur l'optique des réacteurs à notre
rapide mais avec tout ce qu'on avait pu
comprendre en plus c'est à dire
typiquement se dire on fait une
structure de coeur qui est plus efficace
on fait un échangeur de en agenceur
thermique qui entre le sodium et le gaz
et le gaz et l'eau de façon à éviter
tout contact entre le sodium et l'eau
donc il y a des tas de choses qui ont
été faites et c'était ça Astrid c'était
Astrid il y avait 150 ingénieurs
japonais qui travaillaient sur Astrid
c'est-à-dire c'était quelque chose qui
était une vision qui était une vision
internationale pour la raison suivante
c'est que les réacteurs à notre rapide
pouvoir de fonctions il y a une fonction
qui est stabilisée l'inventaire en
plutonium bon pour l'ensemble du parc
du parc français il fallait à peu près
cinq réacteurs pour faire ça vous avez
pas développé une filière pour 5
réacteur c'est par raisonnable donc pour
développer une filière et bien il
fallait se dire avoir la vision de se
dire les réacteurs à notre rapide seront
un outil indispensable d'un utérinaire
durable ça va être important au niveau
international donc il faut qu'on le
développe au niveau international d'où
les collaborations avec les Japonais pas
avec les Américains parce que les
Américains n'aiment pas les neutrons
rapides la raison pour laquelle ils
aiment pas les trop rapides c'est une
question de gestion des déchets les
Américains ont beaucoup de place donc
ils se disent j'ai plein d'endroits pour
stocker mes déchets nous on n'a pas
beaucoup de place donc on a tout intérêt
à limiter la production de déchets alors
les Américains de ce côté là sont quand
même un peu obligés de revenir sur la
situation parce que ils ont plein de
place pour stocker les déchets enfin le
stockage des déchets est dans le site de
stockage de yukaventem sa merde mais
splendidment quoi
c'est marrantes
du point de vue de la science des
matériaux c'est à dire que en gros ils
ont juste pas demandé aux géologues
et comme ce qui se passe c'est que l'eau
qui coule dans les dans les dans les
Yuka Britain se charge en or nitrate et
les ions nitrates corodes les conteneurs
en acier qu'ils avaient prévu donc ça
fait pas bien quoi mais ça c'est alors
du coup ils ont mis des petits
parapluies en titane vraisemblable et ça
marche pas alors que nous le stockage
des déchets radioactifs il y a deux
solutions en Europe il y a une solution
suédoise et la solution française la
solution française c'est de les stocker
en stockage géologique profond et en se
disant on a une barrière qui est le
conteneur du combustible et puis il y a
une deuxième couche qui est désalvéoles
en béton puis troisième couche c'est la
géologie elle-même c'est-à-dire vous
avez des couches d'argile qui font que
si par malheur il y a des éléments qui
forte plouf ils font des petits
précipités dans la couche d'argile ils
bougent plus donc ça c'est la solution
française la solution suédoise c'est je
mets ça dans des conteneurs en cuivre
Extra Pur et ce puits extrapion ce corde
pas du tout et je mets ça sous des
couches de granit alors bon ceci pour
vous dire c'est pas simplement pour
passer en revue toutes les manières de
stocker les déchets c'est que ça vous
donne du des spécificités de cette
industrie c'est il faut impérativement
avoir des compétences qui sont
extrêmement larges vous avez besoin de
gens qui connaissent la physique
nucléaire pour savoir quels sont les
déchets qu'on doit stocker vous avez
besoin de gens qui connaissent la
métallurgie vous avez besoin de gens qui
connaissent le génie civil pour
construire le site de Bures vous avez
besoin de géologues qui permettent de
choisir l'endroit où on va faire le site
et tout ça toutes ces choses là mais
c'est complètement clair que ça ne peut
être mobilisé qu'au niveau d'un état
il y a qu'au niveau d'un état que vous
pouvez mobiliser tous cet ensemble de
compétences
je pense qu'on devrait l'être
pirouette ça non je pense à des tas
d'ouvrage comment je vais vous dire ça
pour moi la souveraineté
c'est quelque chose qui part nature est
au niveau des États pas au niveau des
des
alliances entre état parce que le
souveraineté c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit aux électeurs qui ont délégué leur
capacité de décider à leur gouvernance
alors on peut avoir une souveraineté qui
est déléguée on peut avoir une
souveraineté au niveau de l'Europe par
exemple mais ça veut dire que ça doit
être les les citoyens qui délèguent au
niveau de l'Europe une partie de leur
pouvoir et pas les États qui délèguent
au niveau de leur qui démissionne au
niveau de l'Europe d'une partie de leur
pouvoir de décision donc je pense qu'il
y a une dualité entre la souveraineté et
la délégation de pouvoir par les par le
citoyen dans j'ai l'impression qu'on a
un petit peu perdu si on n'est pas
souverain est-ce qu'on peut s'ouvrir aux
autres bah non ça va avec ça
me semble difficile de s'ouvrir aux
autres si on essaies si on sait pas qui
on est ça se dit oui ça se dilue dans la
nature et on peut difficilement savoir
qui on est si on n'est pas souverain
combien de temps il faut pour construire
un réacteur à neutrons rapides pour
manger nos déchets nucléaires
je pense qu'il faut compter une dizaine
d'années à peu près
c'est une technologie qui est pas
nouvelle technologie qu'on a déjà
utilisé construite et vous savez c'est
un truc extraordinaire la quantité
d'âneries qu'on a pu dire sur les sur le
super Phoenix qui marchait pas enfin la
raison pour laquelle super Phoenix
marcher pas
les écologistes à tous oui enfin bon des
écologistes qui soient pas
anti-nucléaire il y en a quelques hommes
mais ils sont pas nombreux
mais le super Phoenix a eu des défauts
des difficultés de fonctionnement comme
n'importe quel outil industriel qu'on
construit pour la première fois c'est
évident il faut jamais avoir foutu les
pieds dans une industrie pour s'en
étonner maintenant les les difficultés
les été résolues et ce qui a fait qui
fonctionnait pas c'était des argusies
juridiques de la même manière on vous
dit
la drie classique c'est de dire vous
savez la centrale de Brennilis ça fait
20 ans qu'on n'arrive pas à la
démanteler mais c'est d'une bêtise
hallucinante je veux dire on a des on a
développé on a démantelé une quantité
impressionnante de centrale de Parlement
il doit y avoir une douzaine de
centrales qui ont été complètement
démantelés Brennilis la seule raison
pour laquelle elle n'est pas finalement
des mots clés c'est la seule unique
raison c'est des arguties de juristes
c'est des recours contre la fin du
chantier de brennings qui sont faites
par des associations environnementales
c'est-à-dire il faut que les citoyens
sachent ça on sait démanteler des
centrales nucléaires en fin de vie on
sait plus difficilement des mots clés
les boutons à 5 pattes qu'on peut avoir
des laboratoires chaudes des machins
dans le genre ça c'est plus difficile à
faire mais on sait le faire c'est des
laboratoires où on manipule les matières
radioactives et ça comme il y en a pas
d'eau pareil ça veut dire qu'à chaque
fois il faut que vous aviez un moyen de
le démanteler les centrales nucléaires
c'est des produits standardisés donc
vous savez les démons clés si elles
arrivent en fin de vie ce qu'on sait pas
faire c'est des ventes des centrales qui
sont passés par une étape de d'accidents
nucléaires on sait pas des banques les
Tchernobyl on ne sait pas des mots clés
on ne sait pas d'inventer Fukushima mais
je veux dire ça c'est encore un truc
c'est ça demande de rentrer un petit peu
dans le détail il faut être interview et
avoir le temps de parler pour pouvoir le
dire sinon vous avez toujours avoir un
abruti et vous dire on sait pas démonter
les centrales on sait pas comment gérer
les déchets c'est juste pas vrai
comment vous expliquer
que la population était perméable à des
arguments qui pour vous n'étaient pas
valides c'est parce que l'industrie du
nucléaire a pas assez communiqué pas
assez communiqué correctement à n'a pas
réussi à échanger correctement avec le
public je vais vous faire je vais vous
raconter une histoire je vous raconte
plein d'histoires
parce que je pense qu'il y a une
question de relation au public
les Suédois par exemple des habitudes
démocratiques depuis longtemps les
Vikings ils avaient décidé de brûler un
monastère il décider sa collectivement
quoi donc les Suédois car le stockage
des déchets en Suède est fait par une
entreprise privée imaginez ça en France
une entreprise privée on dirait tout de
suite ouh là là ça va être très
dangereux ça marchera pas si c'est une
entreprise privée qui fait ça je trouve
que je connais bien le directeur de
cette entreprise l'idée qui s'appelle
cloud
qui a été membre de la commission du de
la commission la CNE Commission des
nationales d'évaluation des déchets
nucléaires en France c'est là que j'ai
rencontré il m'a expliqué comment il a
fait avec la population
il m'a dit pendant 15 ans trois soirs
par semaine que laisse aller avec deux
de ses ingénieurs parler à la population
trois soirs par semaine pendant 15 ans
il m'a dit c'est quelque chose qui m'a
marqué il m'a dit et je n'ai jamais fait
de réunion à plus de 20 personnes
et la raison elle est double il y a une
raison qui est tactique qui est si vous
faites une réunion à 20 personnes et qui
a deux personnes qui veulent pas que la
réunion se tienne les 18 autres leur
disent ferme et là on a envie que la
Réunion sienne vous faites la même chose
avec 200 personnes s'il y en a vague qui
veulent pas que la Réunion tienne la
réunion qui a pas ça cherchez pas aller
chercher les chercher l'erreur ça semble
étrangement à la commission du débat
public
maintenant la deuxième chose qui est
beaucoup plus profonde
qu'est-ce va dit si vous voulez parler
aux gens il faut les mettre dans une
situation où ils peuvent prendre la
parole et c'est pas la même population
qui est capable de prendre la parole
devant 20 personnes et de prendre la
parole devant 200 personnes donc ce que
j'ai simplement en train de dire c'est
qu'une des raisons pour lesquelles le
nucléaire est pas forcément bien passé
dans la population il y a une raison il
y a une raison qui l'arrogance
l'arrogance tricolore habituelle on sait
ce qui est bon pour vous il y a une
deuxième raison c'est que je crois qu'on
n'a pas voulu parler à la population et
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu respecter la
population on n'a pas voulu respecter la
population en allant parler aux gens
individuellement on oublie toujours
c'est une phrase de Montesquieu que
j'aime énormément monter ce que disait
j'aime bien parler avec mes paysans
parce qu'ils sont pas assez instruits
pour raisonner de travers
je trouve que c'est extrêmement sage
enfin quand je discute avec les gens je
discute jamais avec des grands groupes
je veux dire quand il vous pose une
question ils ont envie d'avoir la
réponse quand votre réponse est pas
claire il vous dit c'est pas clair
réexplique moi j'ai jamais trouvé ça
dans les ministère
est-ce que vous avez vu ces images de
Greenpeace il y a très longtemps une
trentaine ou une quarantaine d'années
plus 40 ans ou ils étaient avec leur
petit Zodiaque qui se prenaient des des
fûts radioactifs vont balancés dans la
mer est-ce que vous avez vu ce type de
est-ce que vous avez entendu parler de
de furadio actifs qu'on va lancer à la
rage enfin je crois que il me semble que
dans la Manche nos chers amis nos chers
voisins britanniques ont fait ça sauf
erreur
je crois mais j'ai pas de connaissance
de première main là-dessus c'est grave
c'est pas grave de balancer ça qui
s'appelle l'effet de dilution
pourquoi les Japonais ont stocké pendant
là ils vont le rebalancer dans la mer
ils ont stocké avec des immenses silos
de l'eau l'eau de des contaminations nos
contaminés pardon mais ça n'avait aucun
intérêt mais ça n'avait aucun intérêt
rationnel mais dans la culture japonaise
la mer est à ce point important et la
population avait été à ce point
traumatisée et par le tremblement de
terre et par l'accident nucléaire que de
remettre une eau même faiblement
radioactive vous étiez à mettre du bord
il y a plus de problème mais de remettre
cette eau dans la mer était quelque
chose qui n'était pas admissible par la
population donc je pense que mais là
aussi il faut il faut aussi respecter la
part d'irrationnel qu'il peut y avoir
dans la
dans le comportement d'une population
moi je veux dire je
stocke pas dans la chaîne alimentaire
bah non
c'est donc je veux dire c'est selon vous
bah oui selon moi
je préfère je préfère croire mais mes
collègues biologistes que les activistes
de Greenpeace c'est désolé mais chacun
ses références
et donc ce que je veux dire c'est que je
pense qu'il faut respecter la part
d'irrationnel qu'il peut y avoir dans un
comportement d'une population parler
avec eux essayer de d'expliquer de
comprendre etc ça je sais pas ça qui
m'énerve ce qui m'énerve c'est pas la
part d'irrationnel c'est la part de
cynisme qui consiste à jouer sur les
rationnels pour pousser une idéologie et
ça j'aime pas
là où on va traverser un réchauffement
climatique qui risque d'être un peu
douloureux on entend dire que on va
avoir des problèmes pour refroidir les
centrales
c'est l'accès à l'eau ça va ça va être
problématique de refroidir les centrales
c'est un gags
oui bon est-ce que est-ce qu'on a déjà
trafiqué les sorties d'eau en injectant
un peu d'eau froide pour que les
thermomètres sont un peu plus bas pour
respecter la norme
on va rebalancer de l'eau un peu plus
chaude c'est peut-être des phases pour
les poissons de rivière d'autres
poissons de rivière qui viendront vous
savez il y a un gars qui a un truc qui a
un boucle
qui est extrêmement intéressant à lire
c'est le retour du castor qui a été
écrit par un professeur d'écologie à
d'écologie à munique donc là une casher
tout va bien c'est professeur d'écologie
université de Munich retour du castor
les banques comment l'écosystème des des
rivières des Alpes ont été modifié par
le fait d'avoir construit des d'avoir
construit des barrages qui permettaient
de qui permettait de domestiquer la
rivière et à montrer qu'une des
conséquences de ça c'est que les castors
étaient revenus s'installer à l'endroit
où on les voyait pas donc je veux dire
il faut pas brutaliser la nature ça
c'est clair la changer un petit peu
changé un petit peu l'environnement
c'est pas forcément un drame non plus
mais ça veut dire que ça se mesure faut
dire il y a peu d'industries qui soient
aussi surveillés que les nucléaires je
veux dire vous avez des biologistes vous
avez des
des spécialistes du vivant qui qui
regardent ça en permanence on est en
train toujours de nous sortir un machin
en disant ah ils ont pas pensé à ça
c'est une catastrophe mais non je
regrette il y a 50 ans de recherche
derrière le CEA c'était fait pour ça
que les gens ne savent pas non plus
c'est tout bête mais il y a moins de
cancers dans les travailleurs du
nucléaire que dans n'importe quel autre
population correctement leur deuxième
contrôlés tellement habitués à être
contrôlé par un service médicaux qui
sont justement créés pour faire ça que
du dial le dépistage des cancers est
beaucoup plus efficace
alors que vous prenez la vous prenez
quelqu'un dans la rue dites est-ce que
votre avis est-ce qu'il y a plus de
cancer chez les gens qui font des qui
sont dans les centrales Lucas ou dire ah
oui bien sûr bah non
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
l'attitude des écologistes
et pourquoi pourquoi ils sont si
arquebotés par rapport au nucléaire
je crois que ça à côté existentiel mais
il y a quelques écologistes au parcoursé
par rapport au nucléaire vous avez
quelqu'un comme bristoland ça fait un
moment qu'il a compris que je veux dire
la priorité des priorités vis-à-vis du
respect de la nature et du respect de
l'environnement c'est de lutter contre
la joie climatique la situation le
nucléaire est une énergie qui produit
quasiment pas de CO2 et en conséquence
de quoi il dit la priorité des priorités
c'est de faire ça maintenant ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas imaginer d'autres
solutions après mais ça veut dire que
quand vous êtes dans une situation
d'urgence le bon sens consiste à
appliquer des technologies disponibles
à préparer l'étape d'après en faisant
des prototypes et à regarder l'étape
d'encore après en faisant de la
recherche je veux dire il faut juste pas
mélanger les échelles de temps donc
c'est aussi des raisons pour lesquelles
je reviens ou de trop rapide les deux
trop rapides dès l'instant où vous lui
permettent de fermer le cycle
c'est-à-dire de ne plus dépendre de la
ressource et de ne pas accumuler des
déchets ça veut dire que vous êtes dans
un nucléaire durable ça veut pas dire
que dans 50 ou dans 100 ans vous
déciderez pas de sortir du nucléaire si
vous avez une solution qui est
techniquement viable ou des solutions de
stockage qui sont efficaces des
solutions de de
réseau électrique qui permettent d'être
mieux adaptés si vous avez ça vous
pourrez éventuellement le faire mais ça
veut dire que vous vous mettez en état
de choisir se mettre en état tuer une
filière nucléaire en se débrouillant
pour qu'elle meurt sous ses propres
déchets ça veut dire que vous préentez
la décision à prendre dans une
cinquantaine d'années
et ça aussi c'est pas bien ça c'est
moralement pas bien les odeurs de morale
pas en verre qu'on a d'habitude ils sont
juste en train de nous forces de
préempter une solution qui empêchera nos
descendants de choisir le prix d'un
réacteur de trop rapide c'est combien si
on le développe à grande échelle
c'est à peu près le prix qui était
estimé pour construire un prototype
d'Astrid ça devait être 7 milliards
d'euros
c'est-à-dire en gros un EPR qu'on
n'aurait pas fait dont on n'aurait pas
fait exploser les coups
pourquoi le péage pas il fonctionne le
père ou pas
fonctionnant
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure le ce qu'on voit dans le
nucléaire c'est la partie émergée de
l'isberg on voit le
les défauts la difficulté du nucléaire
elle vient deux choses et vient d'une
industrie à qui on n'a pas donné de
vision pendant 20 ans et qui a pas
construit de choses et d'un tissu
industriel qui s'est délité pendant 20
ans en Chine vous avez un nucléaire d'un
qui en donne des perspectives et vous
avez une industrie qui en état de marche
et les gens qui ont construit ticham moi
j'en connais j'en connais assez un
espèce de Indiana Jones du nucléaire qui
fait partie des gens qui avaient
construit le parc en France te disent
exactement ça
c'est le même produit là-bas c'est juste
pareil donc là c'est 7 milliards pour
réacteur 1 2 3 rapides il nous faut
combien de réacteurs et de troncs
rapides en France alors pour faire un
autre industrie non attendez pour faire
le cycle bon encore une fois je suis pas
en train de vous dire qu'il faut passer
au notre rapide complètement je dis le
truc qui me semble raisonnable tout de
suite c'est on a un certain nombre de
centrales il faut qu'elle marche donc ça
c'est ce que EDF après le grand carénage
il faut remettre nos centrales en état
de marche bon ça c'est la première chose
en l'état de fonctionner et il faut les
faire durer le temps qu'elle peut se
durer qu'elles peuvent durer pas avoir
une durabilité administrative pas dire
c'est prévu qu'elle arrête qu'elle dure
tant d'années j'arrête quand elle dure
là ça veut dire que on étudie l'état des
centrales le truc qui garantit la durée
de vie d'une centrale c'est la cuve le
reste tout le reste peut se changer donc
ça veut dire que vous étudiez l'état de
la cuve et vous regardez si vous pouvez
passer de 40 à 50 de 50 à 60 que 560 à
80 ans et tant que ça marche et qui est
aborti je veux dire faut vraiment être
au-delà de la bêtise pour faire une
usine comme Fessenheim qui est amortit
et qui marche je veux dire là il fallait
il faut avoir pris des cours pour faire
un truc comme ça bon donc ça c'est la
première chose réussir à refaire marcher
le marche le parc correctement compte
tenu du fait qu'on va avoir à développer
à électrifier une économie qui va
demander beaucoup d'électricité en plus
c'est beaucoup d'électricité en plus la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est de
savoir quelle est l'électricité qui doit
être centralisée qui est électricité qui
peut être décentralisée on va mettre des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur une maison
pour animaux pour pour alimenter la
climatisation de la maison ça me pose
aucun problème je pense que c'est même
tout à fait raisonnable
full taïques made in France tout à fait
mais alors maintenant je dis simplement
déjà au point de vue simplement
technique de se dire il faut savoir
qu'est-ce que je peux
avoir produit de manière distribuée
qu'est-ce que je dois produire de
manière centralisée ce que je dois
produire de manière centralisée la
solution la plus simple c'est de
construire des nouvelles cent plus clair
sur le même principe c'est à dire des
réacteurs à eau pressuriser alors on
peut les faire un peu plus petit on peut
se dire je fais des 1000 mégawatts ou je
fais des OPR parce que j'ai déjà essuyé
les plâtres donc j'ai quand même envie
de bénéficier du fait d'avoir essuyé les
plats et puis je me dis si je veux que
ce truc là soit durable bien il faut que
je ferme le cycle et donc il faut que je
développe des réacteurs à notre rapide
qui me permettent de faire le site
c'est-à-dire de ne pas accumuler des
déchets et pour un parc
électro-ducléaire tel que celui qu'on a
c'est ça qui a 6 réacteur comme ça et
maintenant si vous vous dites l'étape
d'après c'est de dire là je vais être en
tension du côté d'uranium parce qu'il y
a plus de gens qui en vont parce qu'il
devient plus cher parce qu'il y en a
moins bien dans ces cas-là ça vous dit
que les réacteurs à notre rapide y
seront pas là pour fermer le cycle
simplement ils seront là pour produire
de l'électricité c'est à dire que là
vous allez avoir un passage progressif
d'une filière à notre Holland vers une
filiale ne trop rapide mais ça ça se
pense c'est pas des trucs qui se
décrètent comme ça quoi et donc ça veut
dire que ça a combien de temps
pour moi le truc qui est complètement
clair c'est voir arrêter de faire des
PPE bidon et des programmes d'Uranus sur
l'énergie je veux dire faut pas faut
arrêter de faire ces vaches là et se
dire on se donne une grille de lecture
sur 30 ans et on la remet à jour chaque
année et elle est suivie de manière
technique de manière scientifique de
manière industrielle et on arrête de
faire de la com autour de ces trucs là
et on fait de la et on fait de la
technique on construit les choses
on est sur un quinquennat Yves à 30 ans
personne réfléchit à 30 ans sauf des
scientifiques et des stratégies et
encore une fois c'est pas une c'est pas
une fatalité je veux dire c'est ce qui
distingue c'est ce qui dit ça un homme
politique d'un homme d'État un homme
d'État c'est quelqu'un qui en a eu je
vois pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas de
nous un nouveau
était clairement un homme d'État Giscard
était un homme d'État général le général
de Gaulle était un homme d'État
pour moi non
c'était de les faire l'année du 50e
anniversaire de la bombe d'Hiroshima
quand même je sais pas quelle est les
petits génies communication qui les
suggéré ça mais
ça c'était pas une très bonne idée mais
enfin qu'on explique aux Américains qui
restent un peu à leur place pour ça que
Chirac il a dit maintenant trouver
des des secrets défense mais il faut
aussi savoir que pourquoi on a fait ses
essais d'ordinateur suffisamment
intéressant non c'est un truc qui est
très intéressant ça parce que ça ça
repositionne la notion de la
modélisation dans le dans le nucléaire
il y a la modélisation la norme il y a
des gens qui vous disent on peut tout
faire en faisant des calculs pour
concevoir un réacteur c'est juste pas
vrai je veux dire moi j'ai passé ma vie
à faire de la modélisation au sens des
matériaux je sais que le juge de paix
c'est l'expérience alors si on regarde
ce qu'ils ont fait du côté du le côté
militaire l'arbre nucléaire est
complètement justifiée par le calcul
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
d'une part il y a eu un programme de
calcul ces derniers vers qui en était le
patron et l'irrite l'ancêtre de ce
programme de calcul c'est Robert d'autre
et qui pour moi est le haut commissaire
étalon on n'a jamais fait mieux
donc le programme de calcul de prendre
en compte l'ensemble des phénomènes
physiques qui se passent dans une dans
une bombe mais il y a deux points qui
étaient problématiques c'est
l'interaction laservatière et c'est pour
ça qu'il a été fait l'expérience du
laser Mégajoule à Bordeaux et il y a
l'interaction
l'effondrement de la sphère de plutonium
sous l'effet d'explosif et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a un dispositif de ryosine à
côté de Valduc donc ça c'était des
expériences dédiées pour appuyer là où
ça fait mal c'est à dire tester les
modèles à l'endroit où on n'a pas
confiance à l'endroit on se dit il y a
des choses qu'on n'a pas bien comprises
donc ça c'est une vraie logique de
scientifique genre Rostand disait une
vérité qui fait plaisir doit être
prouver deux fois c'est exactement ça et
une fois qu'on a fait ça et bien il faut
se dire j'ai toutes les briques
élémentaires il faut que je puisse
vérifier que je décris de l'ensemble du
système et c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
les essais de bureau les derniers essais
archi instrumentés pour avoir une base
de données pour pouvoir regarder si
l'ensemble de la simulation qui avait
été construite et
valable et donc l'ensemble de tout ça je
pense c'est un bel exemple non pas pour
fabriquer des bombes atomiques mais
c'est un bel exemple de l'interaction
que vous avez entre le calcul qui vous
permet de dimensionner des choses et
puis des expériences dédiées qui vous
permettent d'appuyer là où ça fait mal
et des expériences intégrales qui vous
permettent de voir comment l'ensemble
fonctionne bien pour construire des
réacteurs à neutrons rapides c'est les
mêmes démarches qu'il faut faire il faut
pas se dire il suffit de faire des des
études papier et ça ce qui est la raison
pour laquelle je vous dis ça c'est une
espèce de [__] qui est en train de
circuler c'est la start-up nation c'est
les c'est de se dire en gros il suffit
d'avoir
PowerPoint qui passe en disant je vais
faire des études sur machin truc et
bidule décolle des côtes sur ça et ça et
comme ça j'aurai construire un lecteur
c'est juste pas vrai ça veut dire que
moi ma recommandation c'est pas de pas
faire des startups c'est de dire les
startups que vous choisissez de faire
dans le nucléaire elles doivent
impérativement répondre à certaines
lampes de questions comment on les
intègre dans dans un cycle de du
combustible comment elle s'appuie sur
les connaissances existantes d'un point
de vue scientifique et technique comment
c'est elle commencer ses startups
est-ce qu'elles ont identifié les
problèmes de matériaux les problèmes de
corrosion qui vont se passer et quel est
le prototype qu'on va construire pour
voir si ce truc là peut passer à
l'échelle et tant qu'on fait pas ça vous
pouvez signer tous les contrats de
startup que vous voulez il en sortira
rien que des idées alors c'est une
subvention oui mais c'est mais c'est pas
forcément une mauvaise idée les
Américains font ça beaucoup il y a plein
de startups dans le nucléaire aux
États-Unis
maintenant quand vous regardez ça les
startups dans le nucléaire c'est quoi
c'est un vivier d'idées c'est à dire ils
essayent de regarder par ça des jeunes
des ingénieurs des chercheurs qui sont
créatifs qui sont inventifs le nucléaire
est une étude discipline qui a un peu
tendance à une conservatif et à une
conservatrice pour de bonnes raisons
mais pas toujours pour de bonnes raisons
maintenant une fois qu'on a fait ça on a
repéré des bons on les récupère et puis
on les met au sérieux on les fait faire
des trucs on les fait construire et dire
c'est comme ça que Bill Gates c'est en
train de faire son marché pour qu'on
soit thérapower c'était une idée aussi
de Jacques blavour de faire la
fédération mais ça c'est dans l'espace
c'est juste une petite boutade c'est
quoi un bon conseiller vous comparez les
conseillers
à des champignons
et les champignons qui sont vénéneux il
y a des bons champignons bien entendu
oui je parle des champignons enfin ceux
qui sont franchement
vénéneux
normalement à part la veille de valoïde
qu'on peut confondre avec des mousserons
on sait les reconnaître quoi c'est ça se
voit c'est ce qui se mettent à dire tout
et n'importe quoi avec un implant
considérable vous avez quelques bons
champignons comestibles et on leur perd
assez vite aussi c'est ceux qui vous
cuisinent c'est ceux qui tiennent pas
les choses pour acquises c'est ceux qui
qui vont qui vont gratter un peu et puis
les pires c'est les c'est les toxiques
parce qu'ils ont l'air comestible
c'est à dire ceux qui ont un vague
vernis scientifique qui peut faire
illusion
c'est pas facile à repérer on peut se
faire avoir qu'est-ce que vous pensez
alors dans d'autres fonctions haute
fonction publique on est censé pouvoir
ensuite conseiller des ministres
conseiller des chefs d'État comment vous
expliquer qu'on utilise des cabinets de
conseils c'est parce que la haute
fonction publique est démissionnée c'est
parce qu'en fait ils arrivent pas à
conseiller parlent pas le même langage
que nos politiques est-ce que d'ailleurs
il sort des trucs intéressants moi ce
que j'en ai vu sortir c'était juste pas
bon
le contenu technique le temps des
symptotiquement vers zéro
alors sur la sur la partie économie
politique économie industrielle et
autres bon
j'ai pas l'habitude de juger les choses
que je connais pas mais sur le contenu
scientifique c'était pas bon
c'était de toutes les tissus de banalité
quoi enfin
si je vous dis juste quand même pour
revenir à ça pourquoi on leur demande
malheureusement que quand vous sachiez
quand vous savez rien faire vous
imaginez que vous pouvez tout savoir
c'est dur bah oui
si je vous dis ce qu'ils ne font pas
l'effort nécessaire de comprendre ne
mérite pas d'être éclairé
c'est applicable à qui ça vous les
donnerai pas
à force de dire vous-même
à force de négligence et d'incompétence
la France ne sera bientôt plus qu'une
ruine fumante c'est qui ça c'est de Yves
brescher devant une promotion de
polytechnicien devant des élèves faut
une techniciens à qui je parlais du de
du rôle des corps techniques de l'État
et ça s'applique conseiller et servir il
y a une autre phrase que vous trouverez
dedans et qu'une certaine manière que je
suis pleinement c'est en conseil le
prince mais on sert l'État
maintenant il y a plus que des
conseillers qui servent leurs propres
carrière et qui a plein de gens qui ont
décidé que le verbe se servir ce qu'on
joue uniquement à la forme pronominale
je me sers
mais c'est le reflet d'une société qui
vit dans un qu'on a nourri dans un
espèce d'individualisme pathologique ça
rien d'étonnant qu'on se retrouve à ça
mais je pense qu'il y a une prise de
conscience ce qui s'est passé
j'ai eu cette expérience assez
intéressante j'ai plus si c'était après
la conférence et X ou après l'audition à
l'Assemblée nationale je crois que c'est
après l'audition nationale la promotion
de cette année des jeunes élèves du
corps des mines
m'a contacté il m'a dit on a compris la
paire de claques que vous avez filé au
conseiller dans les ministères on risque
d'avoir à faire ce métier ici quelques
années on voudrait parler avec vous pour
savoir comment on peut le faire bien
non j'ai passé j'ai passé quatre heures
avec eux à discuter j'ai vu des jeunes
qui avaient envie de servir et pas envie
de se servir je pense qu'il y en a plein
je pense qu'il y a une prise de
conscience que ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça
et je veux dire quand la même expérience
que j'avais vu avec les jeunes aynarc
qui me disaient mais on a vraiment on
veut comprendre avec ces corps sardines
qui me disent
on veut savoir comment on peut faire
j'aurais même proposer de faire un TP
pour tout dire je leur ai dit après que
la Commission est rendue son rapport pas
avant je vous enverrai quelques-uns des
rapports que j'avais rendus vous vous
mettez dans la peau d'un conseiller et
vous dites qu'est-ce que je fais de ce
bidule et vous allez comprendre vous
allez probablement vous rendre compte
que vous comprenez pas tout de suite et
vous allez avoir envie de poser des
questions si vous n'avez pas envie de
poser des questions quand il y a un
expert qui vous donne un rapport sur un
sujet que vous ne connaissez pas rentrer
au Crédit Lyonnais
pas conseillé dans un ministère vous
pourriez y faire carrière mais vous y
serez pas votre devoir
vous avez dit nous allons payer nous
allons payer le prix fort de 15 ans de
politique
inepte
c'est quoi le prix fort
vous avez parlé au début c'est le fait
de risquer de prendre le mur le fait
d'avoir une leçon d'avoir un corps
industriel anémique parce qu'il aura
plus assez d'énergie qui est le centre
d'économie c'est ça le prix fort la
situation qui se profilent devant nous
sur un fond de crise énergétique
climatique de désigner astria
désindustrialisation massive du pays de
crise sociale de crise internationale
c'est celle le milieu les jeunes les
jeunes ingénieurs vont être obligé de
résoudre ingénieur ça veut dire
concepteur d'armes si mes souvenirs sont
bons non
bon j'ai une manière de dire les choses
c'est la science c'est comprendre
pourquoi et l'ingénierie c'est
comprendre pour faire
donc ça c'est une manière de voir les
choses je pense que on est face à des
difficultés
graves
ces difficultés sont pas moins graves ni
plus graves que celles que
ont vécu dans nos parents au moment du
choc pétrolier
elles sont pas moins graves ni plus
graves que la reconstruction du pays
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale oui on
a pu en 1970
on est vachement plus sur Terre avec des
puissances qui commencent à avoir les
crocs qui demandent un petit peu leur
part du gâteau ce gâteau se réduit un
petit peu très rapidement on a un
problème d'accession d'accessibilité des
ressources on a un des phénomènes de
raréfaction on a des problèmes de
croissance exponentielle en 1970 je sais
même pas s'ils avaient déjà encore
identifié le sida non c'est plus tard
c'est 79 le sida non
82 et donc c'était la période des
hippies on avait les cheveux longs
c'était cool
alors attendez encore une fois j'ai été
apprécié je vous parlais des difficultés
techniques pas des difficultés
politiques
les livres je pense que les difficultés
techniques sont graves mais qu'on peut
les prendre avant le corps pour peu
qu'on le veuille et moi si jamais ça
j'ai donné à donner à la jeune
génération c'est ce que
j'avais dit dans l'audition c'est c'est
le fait que la reconstruction du pays
elle est entre vos mains et tout ce que
les vieux briscards comme moi peuvent
faire c'est d'essayer de vous aider
c'est pas le faire à votre place donc ça
je pense que c'est ces difficultés
techniques sont des difficultés qu'on
peut surmonter mais on peut surmonter si
on se dit qu'il faut qu'on peut faire
quelque chose je veux dire ma défense
grand-mère avait une manière de conduire
assez particulière quand il y avait un
chat qui traversait la qui traversait la
rue elle relevait les bras au ciel en
disant mon dieu il y a un chat qui
traverse évidemment le chat était
transformé en carpette quand vous êtes
dans une situation comme ça vous devez
tenir le volant et pas lever les bras au
ciel en disant bon Dieu je peux rien
faire donc ça veut dire je dis ce que je
dis aux jeunes mais bon dieu tenait le
volant et c'est pas une question des
technologies je pense qu'il faut pas
confondre le fait des technophiles et le
fait des technologres la technique de
résoudre nos problèmes que si on les
identifie comme problème je veux dire
c'est pas embêtant j'ai jamais vu un
problème sur résoudre en le mettant sous
le tapis quoi donc je pense qu'il faut
attaquer la question il faut se dire bon
ben si je veux avoir la meilleure usage
de la
visage de l'énergie dans le bâtiment il
faut que je développe des systèmes
d'isolation du bâtiment qui sont solides
qui sont efficaces qui sont à utiliser
peu de matière pour faire beaucoup
d'isolation si je veux avoir des aciers
qui remet moi de CO2 il faut que je
fasse de la réduction directe d'oxyde de
fer et je veux dire il y a des tas de
choses à faire moi ce que je dis aux
élèves ça marche bien avec le sodium ça
marche bien les Israéliens sont en train
de bosser dessus là ils ont fait quelque
chose de pas mal regardé
et donc je je vois un peu ce qui se fait
à sa copain dans la pour faire des du
vert à Basser au dos mais encore une
fois c'est pas des trucs qui se
décrètent comme ça dans un des cabinets
ministériels c'est comment je fais pour
garantir la capacité à avoir de
l'hydrogène dans du gaz qui va pas me
bousiller les céramiques comment je fais
à mettre du pour mettre de l'électricité
dans un four qui garde qui garde la
thermique et le transport de fluide à
l'intérieur du du four verrier enfin je
veux dire c'est il y a des défis
scientifiques et industriels qui sont
énormes et qui sont
qui sont motivés par cette volonté de
d'avoir un développement qui est plus
qui est plus respectueux de
l'environnement moi je dis aux élèves
ingénieurs au lieu de me dire j'ai pas
envie de travailler dans tel ou telle
boîte qui vous ou est-ce que je peux
bosser pour que mes compétences puissent
apporter quelque chose comment on fait
pour rien industrialiser le pays sans
énergie
c'est pour ça que pour moi la question
énergétique c'est la partie hébergée de
l'isberg pour ce qui est de d'avoir ça
comme ici nature de la
désindustrialisation du pays et c'est le
problème à résoudre en priorité si on
veut le réindustrialiser si on n'a pas
une énergie disponible souveraine et
dont on a la maîtrise en l'industrie
elle n'aurait pas le pays on fera des
enseignes lumineuses qui seront éteintes
oui
comment comment
ça se passe avec les énergies
renouvelables c'est c'est bien c'est pas
bien il faut le mettre dans le mix
énergétique il faut faire tout 100%
renouvelable
il faut faire des éoliennes des petits
panneaux solaires des centrales de
méthane quel est votre vision sur les
énergies renouvelables la ma vision est
toujours la même c'est une vision
système
les énergies renouvelables par nature
sont dispersés et par nature sont
intermittentes si elles sont dispersées
elles sont intermittentes ça veut dire
qu'il faut que j'ai des moyens de
stockage massif qui me permettent de
gérer l'intermittence si elles sont
intermittentes alors le grand dada c'est
dire oui blanc foisonnent quoi quand
j'ai du ventrique pas j'en ai pas
ailleurs bon d'accord il y a combien de
kilomètres de câbles qu'il faut tirer
entre les deux donc il y a un premier
problème qui est de dire disperser
l'intermittente ça les rend difficile
d'usage pour les applications
centralisées tant qu'on n'aura pas réglé
ce problème de réseau et ce problème de
stockage maintenant pour des
applications qui des applications
locales avec production locale c'est pas
forcément bête c'est même ces mêmes
souvent des solutions qui sont pas qui
qui sont tout à fait raisonnables quand
vous êtes sur une île vous n'allez pas
vous amuser à tirer des câbles pour
aller alimenter l'île c'est vous pouvez
le faire mais c'est pas forcément la
vegan plus efficace
si vous êtes sur une île tropicale vaut
mieux mettre des éoliennes les vent
tropicaux sont beaucoup plus stables
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'au lieu d'en faire un totem il faut
se dire quel est l'endroit où la
solution la mieux adaptée peut-être mise
en œuvre et je pense qu'on a on est dans
une situation où on a une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a une décennie de
décision stupide c'est qu'on a confié on
a confondu l'objectif et les moyens
l'objectif c'est de décarboner notre
notre industrie notre notre économie les
moyens peuvent être les énergies
renouvelables mais pas que et je dirais
du coup on a réussi à faire le
chef-d'oeuvre de ses vertueux à
décarboné une électricité qui est déjà
des carbonée fallait quand même le faire
ce truc là donc je pense que la question
c'est de se dire qu'est-ce que je veux
faire quel est mon objectif quels sont
les moyens et quels sont les moyens les
mieux adaptés à l'objectif je vais pas
partie des gens qui sont hostiles par
principe aux énergies renouvelables je
dis simplement il faut les mettre où il
faut comme il faut pour les applications
qui s'imposent vous avez étudié le plan
des Allemands pour leur transition
énergétique
ce problème c'est quand vous vous
avez pas réglé le problème de
l'intermittence mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire il faut stabiliser les
réseaux et vous savez les réseaux avec
quelque chose qui est pilotable et le
truc et pilotage bah voilà vous allez
retrouver avec du gaz ou du charbon moi
j'avais fait c'est encore un truc que
j'avais envoyé j'ai plus été Alizée ou à
Matignon là il fait une carte c'était
tout bête je regardais le développement
des énergies renouvelables les pays qui
disposaient de stockage massif le vrai
stockage massif qu'on a c'est
l'hydraulique donc ici pays qui stockés
et puis après vous regardez les autres
et ben vous avez des pays qui ont besoin
de gaz et après vous regardez quelle est
l'arborescence des des gazoduc là qui
viennent de Russie il y en a qui
viennent d'Afrique du Sud d'Afrique du
Nord je veux dire il y a quand même pas
besoin de d'avoir fait l'ENA pour
comprendre quoi
si c'est pas c'est pas très stable les
gazons du campement question d'internet
pardon si j'ai raté le sujet Quel est
son avis sur le thorium pour remplacer
l'uranium alors la question c'est on a
fait des centrales d'uranium pour avoir
du plutonium c'est vrai mais maintenant
la bombe
c'est vrai mais c'est la réalité
le thorium on n'a pas la filière est-ce
que est-ce qu'on peut développer la
filière autorium quelles sont les
avantages de la filière autorium
d'ailleurs alors faudra que je vous
envoie un texte absolument magnifique
qu'il est extra texte de l'amiral
recover qui fait la différence c'était
l'amiral recover a dirigé la propulsion
nucléaire aux États-Unis pendant 60 ans
le réacteur académique et le réacteur et
le réacteur industriel et cette
différence c'est essentiellement qu'il y
en a un tout marche bien il est pas cher
le concept est génial puis l'autre il
faut le fabriquer et il y a des tas de
problèmes de plomberie ça coûte cher il
est en retard enfin etc bon le thorium
le thorium c'est effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui est en soi séduisant
parce que justement on n'a pas on sait
pas pour faire des bombes mais et puis
il y a beaucoup de dorium à part que
nous on en a pas donc ça c'est première
chose la deuxième chose c'est gros
chinois et la deuxième chose c'est que
là vous passez vers une autre filière
c'est à dire que vous avez une filière
qui est plus la filière une année donc
qu'il a filière thorium c'est-à-dire que
vous devez pas simplement construire des
réacteurs vous devrez construire des
usines pour fabriquer du combustible et
d'un combustible qui est complètement
différent donc ça veut dire que vous
repartez à zéro quand vous avez à régler
un problème d'urgence vous partez pas
avec une technologie que vous avez pas
c'est juste pas vrai donc ça c'est la
première chose ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas étudier les réacteurs autoriaux
je pense qu'il faut les étudier mais en
ayant en tête que je vous ai dit de la
réacteur nucléaire c'est grosso modo un
dépistien de tronc qui est couplé avec
une machine à vapeur alors le thorium
les réacteurs autoriaux si vous avez un
réacteur assez le fondu c'est ce qui
qu'on nous présente toujours comme le
truc qui est génial c'est une solution
qui est intéressante d'un point de vue
scientifique maintenant c'est le fond du
thorium c'est pas sympa pour les
matériaux l'eau c'est déjà un petit peu
corrosif le thorium le sel
bonjour donc ça veut pas dire que c'est
impossible ça veut dire qu'il y a des
études approfondie à faire et c'est pour
ça que ça me semble une bonne idée
d'avoir des études sur ces choses-là
mais en se disant il faut développer
faire des études sur la manière de le
construire avant de construire un proton
alors et d'autre part il faut que la
filière de combustible soit disponible
maintenant en plus pour comment pour
commencer un réacteur autorium faut un
petit peu de plutôt dire donc si vous
commencez à utiliser votre plutôt dire à
faire des conneries du style du mucy du
multiro-cyclage horaire ou pressuriser
qui va vous pourrir votre plutonium là
vous êtes à peu près certain de plus
pouvoir rien faire question internet
bonsoir avez-vous suivi les auditions au
Parlement si oui quand avez-vous pensé
ou retiré
alors bon comme c'était quand même belle
je vais profiter de l'occasion pour dire
que ce qui s'est passé au Parlement avec
cette cette
commission et pour moi c'est vraiment
remarquable d'abord vous avez un
président et un rapporteur qu'il n'était
pas du même bord il combo c'est ensemble
et quand je dis qu'ils ont bossé ils ont
vraiment bossé moi quand ils m'ont
demandé de venir je leur ai dit écoutez
je veux bien venir mais je vais pas
venir pour beurrer les tartines et les
questions qu'ils ont posé c'est des
questions qui étaient réfléchies et ils
l'ont fait avec toutes les personnes et
ils faisaient un duo qui était tout à
fait excellent parce que quand il se
trouve avec un politique qui répond à
côté ou qui voulait pas répondre ou qui
passait à autre chose il y avait l'autre
qui reposait la même question il y a des
questions que j'ai vu poser quatre fois
donc ce truc là a été vraiment
embarquable les enregistrements il faut
les garder il faut garder le verbatif
des auditions donc rien que ça je pense
qu'il y a il y a matière pour les il y a
il y a eu au moins quelques Audi
quelques audités comme comme Valls comme
Montebourg qui ont dit bah c'était juste
Pipo c'était un truc qui était purement
et simplement un argument un petit
arrangement entre amis et au niveau
électoral à part que ce petit ange hein
on en a fait c'est devenu un totem c'est
devenu doxa c'est le truc quand vous
demandez pourquoi 50 % on dit parce que
50 % voilà bon donc il y a des j'ai pas
appris grand chose sur le contenu
technique parce que je connaissais un
peu le sujet
j'ai appris des choses qui m'ont un peu
stupéfé en entendant un certain nombre
de certains nombre de politiques je veux
dire moi je pensais pas là je vais pas
donner non mais je ne pensais pas
qu'un politique servant son pays pouvait
mentir sous serment devant une
commission
vous savez pas je sais pas vous savez je
pense que ça peut pas en Turquie aux
prisons je pense que ça sert à rien de
faire des lois là-dessus si les gens ont
pas dans les dans leur dans leur veine
qu'on a pas le droit de faire ça vous
leur apprendrez pas vous pouvez faire
mon petit coin ils ont fait les billets
c'était quoi c'était vraiment sciemment
quelque chose qui soit factuellement
fausses mais peut-être qu'ils sont
trompés il faut faire l'avocat du diable
oui oui sûrement
je veux bien être généreux
je retiens pas être naïf
alors au niveau des auditions qui vous
ont passionné mis à part le mensonge
éouté pour vous oui tout à fait
le dynamique de cette commission où il y
a ils ont vraiment essayé au fur et à
mesure que ça avancé envoyer des gens
qui avaient vraiment envie de comprendre
et les 30 propositions qu'ils ont
sorties on pourrait en imaginer d'autres
mais les 30 ils ont proposé sont des
propositions qui sont pensées c'est
réfléchi et moi ce que j'aurais envie de
dire pour une fois que le Parlement fait
son boulot que c'est pas un machin qui
est juste pour cirer les pompes du chef
pour une fois que le Parlement fait son
boulot qui fait un truc qui est
structuré vous avez un rapport où il y a
des recommandations qui sont précises
qui qui disent des choses qu'il faut
faire pas simplement des trucs dont on
peut parler je pense que ça serait
extrêmement utile qui a suivi de ça
qu'on puisse pas le relier des deux
côtés et le mettre sur une étagère mais
que ce rapport-là le Parlement se
saisisse puisque c'est lui qui l'a fait
le Parlement se saisisse de revoir
d'avoir une clause de revoyure et que
chaque année ils regardent qu'est-ce qui
était mise en œuvre des propositions qui
ont été faites parce que je pense que le
travail qui a été fait par le Parlement
sur cette question dont je dis qu'elle
est essentielle et pour notre économie
et pour notre industrie et pour notre
souveraineté le travail qu'ils ont fait
et maintenant quelque chose qui est la
propriété des citoyens et on n'a pas le
droit de l'enterrer
vous avez lu l'intégralité du rapport
est-ce que vous avez noté une partie
concernant la guerre économique et les
ingérences de puissance étrangères dans
notre système énergétique je prends
l'exemple est-ce que par exemple vous
allez discuter un peu de l'Allemagne
je veux dire d'une certaine manière les
Allemands défendent leur industrie et
nous on se met à plat ventre il y a une
différence entre défendre son industrie
faire des croches pas ta copain bah oui
clairement avec les amis comme ça on n'a
pas besoin d'ennemis
je veux dire dans le domaine de la
politique de la politique énergétique au
niveau européen
l'Allemagne a imposé sa politique
énergétique à l'Europe et les Français
se sont aplatis alors il commence à se
réveiller non pas les Français le
français ne s'aplatit pas les
gouvernements français successifs
pour quoi pour faire plaisir
je sais pas il y a une espèce de
mystique de
moi je pense ça aussi quelque chose qui
est dans le dans l'Europe et c'est pas
moi qui l'ai écrit le fait de bien
s'entendre avec ses voisins signifie pas
pour autant qu'on se met petit doigt sur
la couture du pantalon et ce que je
crains voilà chose suivante c'est quand
vous avez quand vous avez rampé pendant
longtemps c'est difficile de se remettre
debout
mais je pense que c'est devenu une
urgence verticalement
donc pour résumer les Allemands se sont
faits sous tutelles russes avec le gaz
et nous on s'est aplati devant les
Allemands donc en gros on s'est aplati
devant tout le monde on a perdu notre
souveraineté
il y a des gens que j'ai vu qui étaient
en charge de l'énergie qui disait que à
terme on allait sortir du nucléaire il
avait comme en bas pour faire ça il le
disait
Théo fonctionnaire français à l'étranger
évidemment quand je voyais ça moi
j'explosais je leur disais vous avez pas
mandat pour faire ça le roi ma femme tu
comprends bien non je comprends pas
alors un moment vous avez le choix entre
vous tirez ou attraper un ulsa à
l'estomac quoi
voir les deux donc vous êtes accrédité
secret défense et même plus
quand vous voyez des hauts
fonctionnaires français ouvrir leurs
bouches avec sans mandat est-ce que nos
services les surveille un petit peu
est-ce que est-ce que nos services de
renseignement côté armé
ce sont un petit peu penché sur la
question de notre perte de souveraineté
sur le centre de notre économie sur des
choses comme ça c'était juste
franchement j'en sais rien je sais
qu'ils font bien le boulot pour ce qui
est tout ce qui est
tout ce qui relève de la sécurité tout
ce qui relève de la dissuasion ça ils le
font maintenant
il en est en gros grosso modo il y a une
dans le domaine du nucléaire ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la partie
militaire a été sanctuaire de ce qui
continuait à être fait et d'une certaine
manière c'était l'endroit où survivait
ce qui pourrait plus vraiment survivre
dans le civil
ça c'est lourde c'est lourd ce que vous
venez de dire celles qui sont la
conviction reste là elle a pas assez
c'est d'être là les valeurs
question internet quid du traitement des
déchets nucléaires au laser et de leur
réduction radioactive alors c'est
peut-être le reformuler les histoires de
Gérard Moreau les histoires de Gérard
Moreau
donc Gérard Moreau qui est un prix Nobel
de prix Nobel de physique et dont la
spécialité c'est de faire des lasers à
très haute puissance donc des réserves
ont compris le paquet d'ondes et on se
retrouve avec des lasers femtosecondes
très très haute puissance et bon il me
disait on peut peut-être en faire des
discuter avec lui on peut peut-être en
faire des réacteurs à fission juridiques
contenus de l'énergie que tu vas
consommer avant d'aller au mieux faire
autre chose que de la finition avec ça
et du coup je lui ai dit on va peut-être
plutôt regarde plutôt ce qu'on peut
faire du côté du redressement isotopique
du côté de du traitement des déchets
donc il est parti de ce côté là
je sais pas si c'est scientifiquement
possible je pense que ça va être
économiquement extrêmement coûteux et
fondamentalement je pense que il faut
pas non plus avoir une psychose sur le
problème des déchets dans les déchets
vous avez des sols déchets qui sont
vraiment problématiques c'est les
déchets à haute activité ville longues
et le plus gros de ces déchets là c'est
le plutonium
c'est 100.000 euros le plus gros des
déchets là c'est le plutonium alors déjà
ce que je vous disais c'est que quand
vous décidez de ne pas vous occuper du
plutonium et que vous le mettez au trou
vous multipliez par 10 la quantité de
déchets tu es intelligent qu'on arrête
les réacteurs de trop rapide bon je
ferme la parenthèse
les déchets les activités de mineurs
donc en plus du plutonium
le stockage géologique profond rempli
parfaitement la fonction c'est à dire
c'est des trucs qui sont pas sympas mais
c'est des trucs que vous mettez au fond
ils sont vitrifiés ils sont avec un
gainage d'acier ils sont dans une dans
un truc de béton et ils sont sous 50
mètres d'argile et ça c'est comme ça
combien de temps ça s'embête de cailloux
la grosse astuce c'est de se dire c'est
encore une question d'échelle de temps
500 ans c'est la durée de vie d'une
cathédrale à l'ingénieur il peut
garantir 500 ans 100000 ans il peut pas
garantir donc la semaine dernière qu'on
puisse garantir 100 000 ans c'est
d'avoir des structures géologiques qui
sont stables pendant 100.000 ans et
c'est pour ça que le stockage géologique
profond est considéré comme la solution
de stockage des déchets nucléaires
partout dans le monde j'ouvre une
parenthèse de deux B aussi
les pyramides d'Égypte c'est combien de
temps déjà c'est 3000 ans c'est ça ça
doit être 4000 4000 ou on sait toujours
pas commencé à rester construit dans le
détail
imaginez-vous on fait un gros trou on
plante notre plutonium tranquillou bien
vitrifié bien bétonné bien alvéolé dans
des couches stables
et dans 3000 ans on a un politique qui
est encore une idée brillante et qui dit
on va faire un trou par là
Commission nationale d'évaluation il y
avait une myriade de sociologue qui
avait des contrats pour
non non
il y avait des contrats pour savoir
comment garder la mémoire sur des
échelles de temps
suffisantes pour le stockage des déchets
bon moi dans son bilan je sais même pas
s'il y aura un être humain sur terre
100000 ans c'est 20 fois la durée de la
plus vieille civilisation sur terre
actuellement c'est 20 fois la durée de
la civilisation chinoise donc bon mais
disserté sur comment rendre le le truc
on pourrait le retrouver en mettant des
pyramides à trois côtés quatre côtés
enfin bref tout ce qu'il fallait un
burst
Marne
et moment aurait ma réaction c'était
mais il faut surtout qu'on oublie
l'endroit où on les a stockés parce que
si vous trouvez dans un bilan une
pyramide d'une civilisation que vous
connaissez pas vous avez qu'une envie
c'est d'aller creuser dessus
donc en fait il vaut beaucoup mieux se
dire je le stocke à un endroit très
profond où il est confiné
de toute façon au bout de 100000 ans il
est plus radioactif nous il a perdu ça
sa radioactivité il sera au fond
il sera toujours radioactif
oui c'est vrai mais il sera pas sorti
parce que les élévations c'est encore un
truc qui est c'est pas forcément facile
à expliquer mais il faut prendre le
temps de le faire c'est que quand vous
avez des atomes pour qu'ils sortent
c'est à dire qu'ils aillent un endroit
où ils sont pas c'est c'est l'entropie
qui gagne j'essaye de disperser les
choses donc pour qu'ils sortent il faut
qu'il fasse du chemin et un atome tout
seul ça fait beaucoup plus le chemin que
des atomes qui sont en paquet et en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que les actinides
ces atomes qui ont encore n'aiment pas
et bien quand ils sortent dans l'argile
plouf il faut un paquet avec les atomes
qui sont dans l'argile ils font ce qu'on
appelle des possibilités et du coup ils
bougent plus donc ça c'est la grossesse
de cette structure géologique c'est
l'argile sert de pièges aux éléments
qu'on veut pas les ai sortir et c'est
pour ça que pour choisir l'endroit où il
fallait le faire bah il fallait des
géologues pour vous dire là dans la
mesure de marque vous avez le lequel
Oxford bien qu'on étudier sous toutes
les coutures il y a pas une il n'y a pas
une
il n'y a pas une faille à 100 km vous
êtes tranquille il y a pas de souci j'en
profite vous parler de faille j'en
profite pour poser une question internet
qui fait référence aux accidents
nucléaires le thé vert contaminé au
césium dans des cultures japonaises à
plus de 400 km de Fukushima qu'en
pense-t-il donc moi je vais je vais un
petit peu muscler la conversation
construire un réacteur en bord de mer on
sait bien parce que on peut récupérer
l'eau de mer ça refroidit bon construire
un réacteur près d'une faille sismique
c'est bien c'est pas bien ouais c'est
pas bien mais ceci dit un truc qui est
très intéressant au Japon c'est que s'il
y a un pays qui s'est construit de
manière antisismique c'est le Japon et
en fait le problème de Fukushima ça pas
été le problème tremblement de terre
c'est ça oui c'est exactement ça le
problème c'est pas été le tremblement de
terre le truc a parfaitement et tous les
autres réacteurs d'ailleurs si on pakani
avec le tremblement de terre avant
qu'ils sous la nuit
s'arrête toutes les réacteurs se sont
arrêtés je veux dire le gros problème ça
a pas été ça a pas été le tremblement de
terre le gros problème ça a été la
subersion par l'eau par le tsunami et
d'ailleurs c'est un truc moi ça m'a
obligé à réfléchir à ça parce qu'en fait
on sait pas bien qu'on se voit contre
les inondations et ça on va avoir à y
repenser pour tout ce qui concerne
l'habitat dans un contexte de
réchauffement climatique qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour pouvoir lutter contre les
innovations mais donc
de construire dans des sur le bord de
failles et c'est pas c'est pas une bonne
idée c'est sûr c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que les Italiens sont pas très
n'est pas là du Duclair enfin nous les
failles bon c'est quand même un peu
calme
en France en France il y a des risques
sismiques quand même non
c'est c'est des bébés tremblements de
terre qu'on a en France c'est pas la
falaise c'est pas la faille de son
Andreas
que je dis j'ai pas répondu à la
question du thé vert en aux avions au
césium je peux pas y répondre je sais
pas
est-ce que vous avez faut pas m'en
vouloir je suis un peu sur tirer des
voitures depuis 2018 vous avez une
voiture pas à Paris c'est quoi comme
modèle
beaucoup de chandelle avait été fait
dans un acier qui était et qui se
corrodé donc c'est pour ça qu'il y avait
eu ça alors après il y a eu une fuite de
sodium à un moment qui était pas une
fuite en fonctionnement qui était une
fuite en cours de qui a été un accident
au cours de nettoyage et là grosso modo
en nettoyant une cuve ou qui avait
contenu du sodium il y a eu un incendie
qui a commencé et puis il y a eu de bord
donc ça arrive ça arrive comme dans
n'importe quelle activité industrielle
je suis pas en train de bouffer me fait
pas passer pour quelqu'un qui n'a aucun
cœur aucun mais mais je veux dire le
fait qu'il y a un accident sur une
accident comme ça signifie pas pour
autant que la technologie est pas fiable
question internet bonjour il y a eu
récemment une tentative de séparation de
l'ASN et de l'ircen est-ce une bonne
chose alors
je peux prendre un peu de temps pour
vous répondre c'est une question qui est
pas facile ça bien sûr c'est c'est pas
facile parce qu'ici parce qu'encore une
fois nos gouvernance ils sont pris comme
des Pieds Nickelés quoi c'est juste
c'est juste incroyable
la SN est une et le gendarme de
nucléaire donc c'est l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire est une autorité une
autorité indépendante ça veut dire qu'il
en réfère qu'au Parlement
l'IRSN et le bras armé de la SN pour ce
qui est des études de des études
d'expertise ou de recherche et l'IRSN
dépend du ministère de l'Environnement
la fusion de la SN et alors vous bon ça
c'est factuel
l'IRSN a une partie de son budget qui
est liée à des contrats avec EDF qui
sont les gens qui contrôlent
donc dépend d'un ministère et d'avoir
une partie de ces contrats qui dépendent
des gens que vous contrôlez c'est pas
exactement ce que j'appelle être
indépendant donc je pense que l'idée
d'avoir l'ASN et l'IRSN fusionné et il
était plutôt une bonne idée en ce sens
que vous aviez une seule autorité mais
par contre il fallait qu'elle soit
fusionnée en tant qu'autorité
indépendante d'autorité administrative
indépendante c'est-à-dire ma référent
qu'au Parlement qu'il fallait d'autre
part que son budget soit assuré sans
être obligé de passer des contrats avec
les gens qui contrôlaient il fallait
enfin que cette entité là et le droit de
faire ce que la SN ne peut pas faire
actuellement à cause de des relations
entre la SNIAS imaginez qu'il y ait une
compétence dont ils ont besoin qu'il
n'existent pas au sein de l'IRSN et
cette compétence ils peuvent aller la
chercher dans une université ils peuvent
aller chercher ailleurs là actuellement
dans l'état actuel des choses s'il a
essayé d'aller chercher une compétence
ailleurs qu'à dire SN il essaie de crier
comme un putois qui en était en train
essayer de les contourner donc je pense
qu'on pouvait assainir considérablement
le fonctionnement en augmentant la
dépendance de la de la structure et
l'étape d'après c'était aussi de se dire
c'est bien beau d'aller parler devant le
Parlement enfin quand vous avez vu les
les auditions pour nommer des gens à la
tête de bidule dans le Parlement vous
comprendrez que le Parlement bon si on
l'aide pas un peu il a un peu du mal à
comprendre qu'on lui raconte donc ça
veut dire qu'il fallait que le Parlement
et en l'occurrence une partie du
Parlement qui s'appelle lopext qui est
commune entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale c'est l'office parlementaire
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques il fallait que ce truc là
Segré d'un conseil scientifique qui lui
permettait justement de pouvoir bien
comprendre ce qu'on lui donnait comme
information et que ce conseil
scientifique soit déjà encombré pas
parce que c'est des experts
autoproclamés de je ne sais dans quel
organisation mais vous voyez
parfaitement sortir une litre une liste
de 30 experts par l'Académie des
Sciences l'Académie des techno et
l'Académie de médecine qui vous disent
voilà être expert vous pouvez là-dedans
choisir des gens qui vous donneront un
avis sur les rapports qu'on vous donne
et c'est à vie là vous en ferez ce que
vous voudrez donc je pense qu'il était
parfaitement possible de faire cette
fusion de manière intelligente au lieu
de faire ça c'est tombé comme la foudre
de Jupiter évidemment la SM a expliqué
que c'était très grave qu'ils allaient
perdre leur indépendance et ça s'est
bien chou-fleurisé les journalistes il y
a un journaliste qui a écrit des choses
intelligentes sur ce sujet là
sylvestruet comme d'habitude
voilà je sais pas si je réponds à votre
question mais en tout cas moi c'est
alors il se trouve que j'avais écrit un
article sur la sûreté sur les analyses
de sûreté parce que je suis comparatiste
dans l'âme comme vous avez dû remarquer
et j'avais écrit avec un copain
mathématicien j'avais écrit un article
sur le brie un article sur les sur les
les autorités de sûreté nucléaires dans
différents pays et sur les autorités de
sûreté dans le domaine de l'aviation
civile et le domaine financier et
d'essayer de comparer la manière dont
elle fonctionnait et je pense qu'on a on
a beaucoup à apprendre là dessus mais le
fait d'avoir une autorité de sûreté
indépendante compétente en référant au
Parlement et qui est qui est challenger
dans les avis qu'elle donne par des
experts je pense que ça c'est une
condition indispensable pour avoir un
nucléaire sur
vous avez un avis sur la voiture
électrique
c'est bien c'est pas bien qu'on passe
tous à la voiture électrique est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir assurer avec nos
centrales nucléaires est-ce que quand on
voit qu'il nous faut à peu près
l'équivalent de 16 réacteurs nucléaires
pour décarboner notre industrie
la voiture électrique derrière c'est en
plus en moins tout à fait toujours
pareil la voiture électrique c'est bien
beau mais enfin si c'est pour apporter
massivement des voitures électriques
fabriquées en Chine je suis quand même
moyennement content
maintenant encore une fois on voyageur
avant les bœufs si vous voulez avoir
vous pouvez pas électrifier un parc de
transport si vous venez pas ensemble
mais Nicolas connaît ça beaucoup mieux
que moi mais t'es pas en même temps en
place tout un réseau de distribution de
d'électricité qui permettent de
recharger les batteries et je vais vous
raconter une histoire encore une fois
dans mon pays en Bourgogne un jour je
vais voir mon pays je vais voir je vais
voir mon garagiste et puis j'essaye
d'avoir la intelligent et j'ai dit ouais
ouais ça va changer vraiment votre
métier de passer à la voiture électrique
et ni m'en parlait pas ça fait deux ans
que je passe mes weekends à aller
dépanner des gens qui sont en panne de
batterie ou qui sont
qui sont pas très campagne ou qui sont
devant une un chargeur de batterie
et lui-même en panne où ils sont devant
une chargeur de batterie qui est pas en
panne mais ils ont pas le bon connecteur
pour le chargeur de batterie et me dit
résultat j'ai augmenté 20 % mon chiffre
d'affaires avec les dépannages que je
fais bon j'ai remballé mon histoire et
voici au moins compris déjà un truc
c'est que si on veut développer
massivement la voiture électrique
faudrait d'abord se demander ce qu'on la
fabrique nous il faudrait que
l'électricité que l'électricité soit
décarbonée pour que ça soit puis que le
réseau de distribution soit à la hauteur
donc moi j'ai pas d'avis il abstracto
sur la voiture électrique faire un
tricorne ou un anneau d'acier ah il faut
peut-être que je raconte là l'anecdote
j'ai cité cette anecdote que j'aime
beaucoup les
au Canada j'ai enseigné quand on donne
leur diplôme d'ingénieur aux élèves
leur donne en même temps à l'anneau
d'acier
et c'est Dano est supposé avoir été
forgé
dans l'acier avec lequel on avait fait
un pont qui s'est écroulé
et le symbole est le discours de
l'anneau
et le symbole c'est de rappeler aux
ingénieurs
que la connaissance qu'ils ont acquise
oblige et qui sont responsables ce
qu'ils font devant la population qui
leur a permis d'avoir cette connaissance
et il garde ses anneaux à leur
maintenant toute leur vie et je trouve
que c'est une très très belle c'est une
très belle image faudrait inventer
quelque chose comme ça questionne
[Musique]
doit-on René nationaliser le nucléaire
pour éviter les dérives de la
sous-traitance
j'ai pas regardé le problème de la
sous-traitance dans le détail donc ça je
peux pas répondre à ça
relationnaliser la relationnaliser le
nucléaire pourrait tout à fait franche
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi on l'avait
privatisé
c'est tout
l'électricité c'est pas bien comme un
autre c'est quelque chose qui justement
parce que c'est l'énergie et le centre
de notre économie c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on peut mettre à la merci de
n'importe quel spéculation parce que
tout le monde paye les dégâts donc pour
moi
c'est pas une question de sous-traitance
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça c'est
la relation de l'État à ses fonctions
régaliennes on est un stratège un état
stratège
si vous voulez cracher le chat n'hésitez
pas il est poilu
je vais en profiter pour vous lire une
longue question donc n'hésitez pas à lui
mettre un petit coup derrière la tête
avez-vous un avis sur l'hydrogène bonne
ou mauvaise idée les japonais ne sont
pas confiants sur l'électrification des
véhicules ont-ils des informations que
nous n'aurions pas question de internet
on des voisins que nous avons mais ils
sont plus proches d'eux
et donc les Japonais il y a deux choses
que les Japonais détestent
c'est David et leur industrie et
la deuxième non pas les étrangers mais
en particulier chinois donc de dépendre
de quelqu'un ils aiment pas et de
dépendre des chinois ils aiment pas du
tout donc moi j'avais besoin d'avoir
discuté avec le patron de la recherche à
Toyota il me dit je comprends pas les
Européens vous êtes en train de vous
mettre en dépendance
pour ce qui est de la voiture électrique
des batteries qui sont fabriquées
massivement en Chine et qui sont 70% de
la valeur du véhicule donc vous êtes
juste en train de tuer votre industrie
c'est ce que disait les le patron de
Toyota alors il exagérait peut-être j'en
sais rien mais mais le résultat c'est la
chose suivante m'avoir d'Anaïs c'est de
dire alors justement pour continuer avec
les avec les Japonais il se trouve que
ils ont fait beaucoup d'études sur
l'hydrogène et je m'étais même amusé moi
au moment où on a commencé à s'exciter
sur l'hydrogène en France aller faire un
voyage d'étude au Japon je passais une
semaine à bosser 16 heures par jour à
visiter des laboratoires visiter des
centres techniques visiter des
usines visiter des visites des
ministères
sur l'hydrogène j'ai terminé cette
semaine là j'avais envoyé une note je
crois que j'avais envoyé une autre à
l'Elysée à Matignon et à Bercy
et j'avais passé à la fin de cette
semaine de travail j'avais passé deux
heures au midi avec le 3 du Midi et
discuter de la différence entre pas de
la stabilité des front de flamme de
l'hydrogène dans les turbines au sol
parce que les Japonais ont aussi l'idée
de faire de l'électricité avec de
l'hydrogène et des turbines au sol et
c'était le 23 du ministre à quand je
suis revenu en France j'ai pas trouvé
une personne dans un ministère qui
connaissait vraiment la différence dans
l'utilisation entre l'hydrogène et le
méthane donc
bon passons sur cette histoire là alors
maintenant alors l'hydrogène
fuites au méthane qu'est-ce qui allait
se passer avec de l'hydrogène en 6 ans
j'ai jamais réussi à faire cette
expérience ça vaut plus haut bah oui
donc
encore une fois je crois qu'il faut se
méfier c'est de l'intérêt de personnes
de survendre une solution je pense que
quand on a une solution techniquement
viable il faut se demander quelle est la
niche quel est l'endroit où cette
solution est la plus pertinente et faire
les études pour voir si je peux si je
peux la développer à cet endroit-là et
pas simplement décréter parce que j'ai
lu un article dans Le Nouvel obsc que
l'hydrogène je veux dire il y a un
moment ça m'a franchement énervé de voir
que ce qu'on faisait sur l'hydrogène
c'est des grosso modo de lire rifting et
puis de se dire que ça allait sauver le
monde quoi enfin il faut arrêter je veux
dire il y a des gens sérieux qui bossent
sur l'hydrogène l'hydrogène est un est
un est un matériau industriel qui est
utilisé pour des tas de choses et c'est
tout à fait intéressant de voir
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en faire mais je
vous parlais des japonais ils ont
parfaitement réfléchi au truc mais ah
ils ont compris qu'ils allaient pas le
fabriquer avec des renouvelable parce
qu'ils ont pas assez de place pour
mettre l'air doublable ils avaient pas
envie à l'époque de relancer lors
nucléaire encore maintenant ils sont en
train de dire venir mais donc il pouvait
pas l'électrifier comme ça
l'hydrogène qu'on a actuellement c'est
quand même essentiellement du réformage
du gaz naturel donc ça veut dire que
côté côté émission de CO2 c'est pas un
cadeau et puis en plus le gaz naturel
on l'importe de genre dans les Japonais
on parle du tout envie de dépendre donc
le résultat c'est que les visions des
Japonais de l'hydrogènes c'est je vais
en Australie je prends des tours de
carbonifères que je mets sur de l'eau
bouillante c'est l'eau bouillante ça me
permet de dégager l'hydrogène que je
mets dans des dans des
bateaux que je ramène au Japon et au
Japon je mets des camions qui vont sur
des points de distribution de
l'hydrogène c'est pas idiot mais après
que quand vous regardez un peu l'intérêt
de la chose ben les tours carbonifères
vous font de l'hydrogène mais font
autant de CO2 donc ça veut dire que vous
avez fait un hydrogène qui est tout
aussi noir et le transport dans des dans
des bateaux encore une fois le diable
est dans les détails l'hydrogène c'est
beaucoup plus froid que le méthane donc
les métiers ça marche pas donc il faut
développer des bateaux qui sont bien
adaptés au transport de l'hydrogène et
ça c'est pas encore fait donc j'essaye
de vous montrer comme ça qu'il faut pas
avoir nous case en disant c'est génial
il faut le faire ou c'est stupide c'est
pas la peine il faut comme d'habitude
particulier là où ça fait mal regardez
où sont les difficultés et se dire
est-ce que les difficultés c'est pas
pour ne pas le faire c'est pour dire
qu'est-ce que je dois faire pour
supposer pour dépasser ses difficultés
vous avez vous avez suivi les
platinoïdes et la filière hydrogène ou
pas du tout non pas du tout question
internet
la comparaison de coups du mégawater
entre
leprincy au Royaume-Uni à 105 euros et
le parc éolien offshore Normandie 45
euros ne montre-t-elle pas que
l'électricité nucléaire a perdu la
bataille économique tant et grande la
différence
la question que vous pouvez
raisonnablement vous poser c'est que
quand vous dites quel est le prix de
l'électricité au pied de l'endroit où on
le produit vous avez juste oublié qu'il
va falloir la transporter à l'endroit où
vous allez l'utiliser
et que les coûts de stabilisation du
réseau sera énorme et qui est les coûts
de transport du réseau sont énormes donc
ma réponse est non
il n'y a actuellement plus de haut
commissaire au CEA depuis trois mois
qu'en penses-tu
ah voilà je peux vous le dire très
clairement c'est que ils ont toujours
pas compris que c'était utile
donc c'est très simple je pense que on
est dans une situation qui est
complètement hallucinante ou ça les
emmerdait d'avoir un commissaire qui
faisait son boulot il se faisant
démerder pour endommer un car rien fait
et maintenant qu'il est parti il y a la
retraite et ben grosso modo ça traîne
des pieds et je sais pas convaincu je
serai pas surpris que l'administrateur
général est convaincu quelqu'un d'un
groupe assez que finalement il y avait
pas besoin de quelqu'un qui était
indépendant pour donner des avis
scientifiques avant de prendre des
décisions et j'en sais rien
je sais que c'est suspendu entre ciel et
terre ce truc là je pense que les gens
qui ne nomment pas un haut-commissaire
dans une circonstance où on va relancer
l'électronucléaire et qui se prive d'un
conseil indépendant pour prendre des
décisions raisonnables ces gens là
devraient avoir du mal à se regarder
dans la glace
question la même question que la
personne qui a posé la question entre
une clip point et le parking quel vin
préfère notre invité plutôt sauter ou
Saint-Emilion
plutôt Saint-Emilion mais je ne le dites
pas parce que je suis en Bourgogne et on
Bourgogne c'est lequel ah je devrais
Chambertin ou Chablis
alors question on sait on a déjà passé
pourquoi les questions arrivent en
double
est-ce que vous avez des bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté je
voudrais trois livres qui ont marqué
votre votre parcours de vie alors ça
peut être des trois ouais non mais si
vous voulez quatre j'accepte le 4 mais
mais quatre bouquins quatre bouquins
importants pour vous pour votre
qui ont construit votre pensée ou qui
vous ont aidé dans la vie autour du
sujet en question ça peut être n'importe
quoi
alors je dirais deux choses
je dirais les Pensées de Pascal c'est un
livre que je relis chaque année
et de la démocratie en Amérique de
Tocqueville parce que je pense qu'il
décrit parfaitement la situation dans
laquelle on évolue et que Tocqueville
est toujours quelqu'un
d'extraordinairement lucide
et alors maintenant je vais vous parler
de du côté j'ai quand même vous donner
deux livres scientifiques qui sont liés
d'une certaine façon aux questions qu'on
a qu'on a discuté là
j'en rajoute un
ça compte pas donc
ça fait 4 bouquins plus d'accord alors
les livres scientifiques j'ai quand même
vous les donner vous y couperez pas et
un livre que je trouve remarquable qui
est le livre qui a écrit un monsieur qui
était un très grand monsieur qui
s'appelait Maurice dubiana qui est le
père de la médecine nucléaire en France
qui est quelqu'un qui s'est beaucoup
battu pour le pour la prévention contre
le cancer du poumon et qui était qui
avait fait sa thèse avec Joliot Curie
donc là on est vraiment dans l'histoire
et Mauricio Bada il est mort à plus de
90 ans et quelques années il avait écrit
un livre qui s'appelait la science au
cœur de nos vies et c'est un livre qu'il
avait écrit sur toute la science à
l'usage de ces petits enfants et arrière
petits-enfants
donc ça c'est un livre qui est c'est un
livre qui est très très beau il y a un
deuxième livre que j'aime bien dans le
dans le domaine de l'énergie c'est aussi
un grand monsieur qui est disparu très
belle prématurément qui était le
conseiller scientifique de
Tony Blair de Gordon Brown qui était un
professeur de physique statistique avec
Cambridge qui s'appelait David McCain
livre qui est bourré de grandeur c'est
un livre ou en gros on calcule avec les
mains qu'est-ce qui fait que les choses
sont possibles ou pas dans le domaine
des choix énergétiques économie
soutenable sans air chaud il a été
traduit effectivement économie
soutenable sans air chaud sans l'air
chaud et c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
très beau alors maintenant un autre
livre
un troisième livre littéraire il y a le
dernier livre de François chain que je
trouve extraordinaire
un chemin partagé c'est
le titre le titre exact
une bêtise voilà c'est ça une longue
route pour m'ouvrir le champ au champs
chinois d'origine poète qu'elle grave
peintre il est membre de l'Académie
française et il écrit dans ce livre
Comment est-ce qu'il est passé de la
culture chinoise à la culture française
et comment il a intégré les deux et
c'est un livre qui est extrêmement
émouvant une dernière question Internet
et après j'ai un conseiller à vous
demander bonjour venant d'un étudiant
ingénieur en robotique d'une petite
école comment je puis comment puis-je
faire pour servir la France
faites votre métier
vous pouvez servir la France je veux
dire ça il y a la France c'est il faut
toujours
ma règle ma règle a toujours été de
choisir l'endroit où on se sentait le
plus utile
et on l'endroit où on est le plus utile
c'est l'endroit où on est le plus
efficace en général donc choisissez
l'endroit où vous pouvez bien faire de
la robotique et vous servir la France
deux questions a-t-il une utopie
énergétique réseau production
consommation et j'enchaîne tout de suite
que pense-t-il du projet ITER
il faut je pense qu'il faut il faut
faire des études commeitaires mais il
faut pas les vendre en disant qu'on met
le soleil dans une boîte c'est juste pas
vrai
alors ce serait la dernière question qui
n'est pas une question c'est laisser un
conseil aux jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose d'un
périssable
au boulot
faites bien ce que vous savez faire
considérer que considérez que vous avez
quand vous avez un talent vous devez
absolument l'utiliser quel que soit le
talent que vous avez et vous devez
l'utiliser au mieux c'est comme ça que
vous servirez vos contemporains
Yves brescher merci
[Musique]